foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you tickle
hello
hello
foreign
I know I said I wanted to start Speed
running today
but I think I like challenge runs chat
which technically a speed run is
for whatever reason today I had to be in
my Bonnet I'm like I want to do this
I don't know how hard this is gonna be
it could be easy it could be impossible
it's probably been done before
I have no idea
but we're just gonna do it all right
frostbot only maybe in the future that
actually sounds hilarious
yeah the no glitch Speed Run I I
definitely want to do that at some point
I just have a bee in my bonnet
for this
game over Vigor only run
I mean if you can do level one then
hopeful I don't know if I can do level
one
as you enjoy Joy is fantastic she's done
had another great day or another good
morning here
she spent all morning on the porch after
our super long walk and now she is
asleep in the bedroom
so she's doing fantastic
yeah this is gonna be weird
because I think you all are gonna
require me
to use
the wretch right
just level one level ten whatever it is
everything and then only level Vigor
from that point on
I think that that has to be one of the
requirements right
Base Cam today oh yeah I just like
talking with it I love this starting
soon screen so I'm gonna use it
also somebody said it yesterday
um to start a joy treat fund so I did
it's the pin comment
if you want to help out with that
it'll all go to getting Joy more treats
as she deserves because she's a cutie
patootie
does Joy ever bite you Joy has never
bitten anyone in her entire life she's
too sweet to hurt anything
besides a squirrel
she'll mess up a squirrel man
those squirrels piss her off
Joy gonna be making more money than Jake
I hope so she's gotta pay rent by the
way
we're paying rent now and she's a part
of it she's got her pet pet rent which
is a thing
that's actually a thing she it's it's 25
a month for her to exist
there it is baby
let's go Twisted enjoy Pips please
that's going right to Joy
thank you man
appreciate that Dono going right to the
treats hi cat how are you hope all is
well
I'll see if online payment Works enough
for me to lead by example
all right
thank you twisted for the four dollars
and twenty cents I wonder what that's
referring to
anyway every dollar helps out to that so
I appreciate it guys
how you all doing today
my pure golden retriever used to bite me
every time she sees me lots of friendly
bites oh well joy play you know she
nibbles but she doesn't bite
you know I shouldn't do that
is there a jake treats fun I would say
that's the super chats
super chats helped me out uh memberships
help with me but the joy treat fun will
be for joy
because that goes into a separate
account
or a separate thing
all right let me take my shoes off so
when I get up you all can say feet
[Music]
all right
when's the new lore video gotta drop I'm
not really inspired by anything right
now man so I'm kind of just streaming
and having fun with it
so one thing I wanted to talk about real
quick uh which is why I kind of want to
do more of these challenge runs that I'm
finding extremely fun to do
[Music]
um
feet picks for free now 5 000 members I
will start a legitimate only fans and
I'm not kidding
um okay
uh
so you guys know the roon roulette video
I made right we did the whole roon
Roulette Challenge run took us three
four days to do and then it was like two
days of editing into a video right
grim
GG and chat for good girl Gigi and chat
for the good girl Jojo
6.90 69.
thank you man
I appreciate that it goes right to Joy
um thank you I appreciate that uh
so I made I made that video right the
Rune roulette video and I think I titled
it this Elden ring challenge made me cry
and well I actually just originally
called it Elden ring the movie Rune
roulette and I'm not gonna lie to y'all
that video flopped
it did in comparison right
uh to to all the other videos it flopped
I was just like oh man that sucks
it is what it is it was different from
what I usually make so it's like I
understood it right
H4 what up man
keep up the streams bro they're amazing
enjoy joy I love streaming man I hope
you guys like watching it I appreciate
the Super Chat thank you
thank you thank you
um what was I talking about that video
flop the the roon roulette video kind of
flopped
and then I changed the title
like a week after I uh put it out right
a week later I changed the title to this
elder ring challenge made me cry
damn you guys going crazy look at this I
don't know what bepis is
Nick but thank you for the six dollars
and 90 cents
69. guys are funny with your numbers
thank you very much
thank you thank you change the title
and now it is
out of nowhere the video is getting more
and more views
like I don't know how I can show you
guys this
it's crazy
you know because it kind of got its
initial views and then flatlined right
at about 8 000 views and I was like man
that sucks that just means people didn't
click it whatever
and then I changed the title and it just
went like it would literally this line
it goes like this
like holy it's gotten like 15 20 000
more views in the last two days like
I
that's good we like that
so if I can do more of these challenge
runs on stream record them and then put
them into videos that sounds like a
great time to me because for lore videos
right now I'm kind of just waiting for
DLC or something to hit me you know what
I mean I I have to really like
um I have to be really invested in what
I'm researching and and designing the
video like the cinematics of a video
when it comes to lore when it comes to
the Cinematic uh questline stuff like
that
I have to be like in it inspired and
want to do it right now I want to do
challenge runs that's kind of I I go off
how I feel and I think that leads to the
best content
you know what I mean
bigger tastes nice I wonder if it does
you guys think the Crimson flask tastes
good
the over-exaggerated emotion on the
thumbnail too
I'm gonna use my face in a thumbnail
ever
without looking what is your most
watched video the radon video by a mile
it has almost a million views
why not roll the dice for it well we're
not rolling the dice this entire run you
know what I mean this is all I'm only
putting stuff into Vigor so let's let's
talk this out
hold on let me get my music back on
I also made a preset character for you
guys
I think we should go with wrench
personally I think we should go with
wretch
because if we start with like Samurai
whatever it is
it kind of
defeats the purpose of the run you know
what I mean like it's supposed to be
only vigor
so
then we only put it in Vigor so
everything else will just be base 10.
however what that is going to lead to is
me upgrading the Bonk stick
and then getting the serpent Hunter as
soon as possible and upgrading that
that's what's gonna happen
so if you make it to 99 Vigor will you
be able to upgrade other things no
it is only Vigor maxed out and then we
try to beat the game that way
that's the entire challenge
go whatever as high as Vigor only Vigor
I think we should do wretch
or are you guys okay with not doing that
but here's my preset
I made this this morning for the
thumbnail
what do you think
you can't see
hold on I'll just I'll disable chat for
a second I don't know how to get them
closer
what do you think
[Music]
red for vigor
laughs
he has become the Crimson flask
exactly
oh my God
beautiful
it's disgusting so perfect
I have not come up with a name though I
need help with that what's what's our
name boys and girls
what are we rocking with here
[Music]
we have to come up with a decent name
John vigor
Le flask
okay real creative let's just call him
Vigor right
on bigger because of the John Souls
ma'am you guys like John vigor
I like John thicker a lot
that's funny
I say John vigor
foreign
since the flask removes your injuries
and pain it would taste good but by
association and conditioning
good point
all right we're gonna go with John Vigor
let's not overthink this one
let's get our golden seed it's honestly
the only one we do
so okay
press one in chat if I should just do
retch or press 2 if I should use the
class that has the highest amount of
vigor
but it will increase the other
attributes
I'll do whatever you guys want
hmm
saw a nine in there by a mod excellent
all right we're gonna have to do a poll
we're gonna have to pull it
start pull
question mark
wretch
or
highest
Vig ask community
we're pulling it
this no I'm not gonna mess
gotta pull it
y'all were way too fast
way too quick with it
make sure to vote
the retch beams are better you're not
wrong
if you don't choose wretch you're
getting the time out okay buddy okay
buddy it's pretty close but it's 57 to
wretch currently it's getting lower
though
hmm
it's getting lower and lower
I'll let it go for another few minutes
another minute not even a minute
which class does have the highest figure
I think it's the uh
hero right
let's see
15 11 no it's not so far it's Vagabond
15 11 14 10 9 10 12 11 10. so it's
Vagabond Vagabond has the highest figure
with 15.
looks like it's going 54. it's pretty
much a tie it's really close to a tie
guys
foreign
guys are close with this one I like it
but I think it's gonna stick it 54
percent
I think it's gonna stick right there
oh it keeps getting lower
all right
I think that's enough votes
53 of you said wretch so it's very close
but I'm ending the poll now it's at 51.
oh man okay well it was close guys sorry
there's there's your uh statistics 51 to
wretch it's bigger 48. that's insanely
close but we're doing it all right
you guys ready for this
I'm not
we're I don't know if this is going to
be extremely hard or extremely easy uh I
don't think it's gonna be easy
at all
but maybe
I don't know where the one percent went
that's weird because that did not add up
to 100.
all right let's go baby
as always we go hard we go fast we go
strong
we gotta get going no my encoding chat
no
uh oh
why is my computer weird every time
my computer is has really gotten weird
ever since I moved
are you gonna put a timer on the screen
I mean it's not a speed run so I don't
know why I would do that you know what I
mean
hold on chat hold everybody hold
um let's try this
this recording yeah
because I really want to record
so people don't complain
so insanely hard like they did on the
last one
I think we should be good now
uh start recording let's see if it
breaks again
it is excellent okay that didn't do
anything
how does that affect that that is insane
to me
vbr Maybe
I thought this is a speed run
it's a Vigor only run as it says where
did what
huh
okay let's do this I really want to be
able to record this chat
we might not be able to and stream at
the same time
I'm just doing test recordings
dude bruh
I guess I can't record
okay
well
we're doing it like this
let's go
so now I can't stream and record at the
same time
that sucks
what happens in 99 Vigor then we're done
leveling
we are done timer might make sense if
you may do many different challenges
I mean do you guys want me to use a
timer
so it's really hot in here
listen to melna
okay
do that X
the stream lengths still show
is it hot because you're in the room
um I mean it's really cold outside but
it's really hot in here probably because
you know two PCS of fat light on my face
and then whatever else
Fortune is
a sign how much do you think John Vigor
weighs so every his head chest abdomen
and legs are as high as they get
so he's just a stud
but do you guys want a timer
sure to seek I guess I could make one
ring where's Joy she's asleep in the
bedroom
even if it does violate
the
golden
all right
so this time I'm definitely saving Rick
for last I am not going down there
yeah I was gonna say it's not a speed
run so I don't know why we'd have a
timer
we're just trying to do it
you know
any secondary goals for the Run besides
the main bosses finish up a specific
dungeon get a weird item get a random
side boss
nope
here's the question though
and I want you all to think about this
God what a glorious man
should we do all remembrances
I think we have to
personally
hold on
oh it is on cool
timers are cool
I mean I guess we could just have a
timer up for like how long it takes
right to to do this thing
it won't take long
hmm I don't think you can
it will be too challenging
dude why did you say that
now I have to and it's just cause you
said that because I'm a freak
you said it's too hard so now I have to
do it
damn it dude
[Music]
okay we'll do all remembrances
oh I think you saw me
toxic Echoes from the Perry hotter run
you guys know I finished it last night
off stream
I just did it
felt good
ER and everything
I just couldn't do it on stream it was
the worst experience ever
and it wasn't that bad it was just I was
so [ __ ] pissed from chat being
annoying yesterday and the day before
that I was just
not in the right headspace to get that
done
oh I just beat Melania I didn't do the
rest
should have specified that
I think radagon might have been harder
hi Peter
like button if you haven't smashed the
like button yet you might as well just
do that real quick I'm gonna move Joy's
treat fun down here actually
right above our runes
[Music]
does that look okay right there
yeah
oh
hello sir
well if you're watching the end of the
stream the night comment thing you guys
gave me just it she can't Dodge it so
it's just like a matter of time before
she dies right
so
we did find out a lot about Millennia
yesterday
that was weird now if you spam her with
a bunch of attacks she just does
waterfowls like crazy
so there must be something in her AI
that based on the amount of time she's
attacked
is when she will use the waterfowl and I
think it it's based on distance so like
if you're shooting arrows or you know
the star thing we were using
then she just like does it all the time
but you I can play turning root Aid you
you need oh to the
we have to do a lot of setup here guys
to start the stream by the way
so get ready for that to treat him with
weird like waterfowl really isn't even a
big deal you know John
once you know how to dodge it and you
can kind of baiter out of doing it stuff
like that it's really not that bad
stage two is kind of ridiculous though
she can just kind of do whatever all the
time
yeah I stream to have fun angel
and when I'm not having fun I just don't
want to stream so I just didn't
so uh you know hopefully
hopefully
now that we're not doing that build
those people won't be won't be a thing
why is the stream lagging
is it
for me it says it's not now
um let's go get a bunch of stuff
we're doing a lot of setup now
so now your face cam streamer I've been
streaming with a face cam for multiple
weeks now
multiple multiple weeks
already picked that up
what's a goober
okay we're gonna get this because we're
gonna have to upgrade this box stick as
much as we can
because we're going to use it all the
way to getting the serpent Hunter
because
otherwise I think we're screwed
I guess there might be other items that
are possible to use with the attributes
that we have
but I'm not aware of them right now
I'm getting as many runes as I can
also what do you guys think of the
thumbnail
I went hard on the thumbnail
yeah we're gonna do all remembrances
Rochelle for show
use the club the entire game
this club
yeah we're gonna use the serpent Hunter
because it does not require attributes
to use
what up Trey
grave robbing pigtails I did give her
pigtails actually it's a guy it just has
girl hair
it is what it is
boring all right bro
you just want me to struggle
which
will still happen
what's the hardest challenge you've done
so far honestly the only challenge I've
done
is the uh the roon roulette one but I
would like to do more
are you planning on using only
vigor-based talismans yeah
that's the plan I don't really know
where those are to be honest with you
despite it takes me by any interest all
I know Now's the Time okay let's go get
we're gonna sell all those we need to go
get our sacred tears we need to go get
more upgrade stuff a lot of setup to
start boys
foreign
about time you got to level Vigor that's
that's kind of the meme because the last
challenge we did we never got Vigor at
any point
now it's gonna be only bigger
so I bitched and moaned about it as much
as I can
you're not using talismans to boost your
damage
I mean we can do that too
oh we did a randomizer run I didn't
think of that as a challenge though I
thought it was just interesting
all right the Crimson medallion
uh oh
okay we're good
you could run spiked Cactus get some
bleed build up
does that require attributes
to use
also at some point I'm expecting a phone
call
uh at some point today so if that
happens I'll have to step aside for like
five minutes
I'm trying to get these movers to bring
in the couch
and they're on holiday the entire
weekend
I'm trying to get them bro
how's it different from room level one
uh the fact that I level my vigor
and only that
I would say is the main difference
obviously
the [ __ ]
no
that's
sick
as far as eight strength ten decks so we
can use it okay
I've never seen or used that before so
that should be fine
we can do that if we want
no weapon scales with vigor
you would think like the uh
I don't know the Blasphemous blade
wood or something like that
right
I don't think I'm gonna need the ones
that are down there
foreign
[Music]
oh yeah I said Cactus sorry
I was like is there a cactus weapon
it should be a somber one excellent
pretty sure this guy should be easy
have you tried a no death run not yet I
would like to do that in the future when
I feel like I'm good enough to do so you
know
did you plan the route
no
I didn't
[ __ ]
you think I planned things out
foreign
I probably should though you know
oh [ __ ]
what
that is a giant AOE
what's the character you are running and
why isn't it Thomas the Tank Engine
his name is John vigor
as you can see he's quite thick with it
no endurance will make this very hard
that's a good point
a very good point
so we'll have to be patient
and just upgrade a lot
get our swings in when we can
you know what I mean
it goes out like 500 Souls not too
worried about it
did not know he would turn like that
here we go
that is not what I wanted to do
it is not worth it
okay sometimes this guy's annoying and
sometimes he's super easy
right he pulls out pull out game strong
on this one
thank you
it's a [ __ ] guy man
oh my God
yep
super annoying
easy peasy
we can actually put this on for now the
the roar Medallion because that uh this
is a roar attack
so it'll boost us even more huge
also minimal scaling will have you rely
on bleed a lot which for immune bosses
would be hard
why would I have to rely on bleed
just be like I don't know strength
mostly could be wrong on that one
can you use other Talisman to boost
stats
if it's not Vigor I can't boost it
if it if it increases like I don't know
physical damage or or other stuff like
that then yes
like the physics you know what I mean
but if it's not Vigor I can't I can't
boost it
otherwise I think we'd be going against
what we're doing here you know what I'm
saying
but I'm just doing all the setup stuff
no scar seals
not for this run
because it boosts other stuff besides
Vigor it does Boost Vigor but it also
boosts other stuff I don't need that
crab eggs
yep
can you use pots I can use whatever I
want
but I can only upgrade bigger
I'm debating on summons I always say if
if there's a summonable character
outside of the Arena that's a part of
the game
then I think it's fine to use that like
Melina from morgot or Roger for Margaret
or um we found out yesterday we can use
um shabreary against Godfrey which I had
no idea that was a thing until yesterday
thanks Kellen
good to have you here
welcome
mimics here summon only
I don't know
but you could use fraught I can use
Frost pots on Melania yes
I can that's that's fine it doesn't
increase anything you know yes
if I can hold them I think I can
all right three points in the bigger
right there boom
look at that
sponsor no I have to go this way
summoned shibiri and nepheli have them
give each other bad looks
how do I say your name uh is it aarine
Irene Irene
I know how to pronounce that
you know hopefully that'll be in two
days Trey when I'm fighting
Melania it's just Aaron got it
got it gotta get it
I haven't seen it spelled that way
before
oh my dad texted me everybody hold
um getting the truck I'm just gonna pick
me up at your school and drop me off
there
cool
thanks for holding
say Hi to Dad I'm sure he's uh probably
watching the Stream
he's at work but uh I think he has me on
a side monitor
grab this over here my mom is in labor
for 26 and a half hours
I think it was
delirium delirious and it convinced her
to spell it that way delirium right
hey it is what it is
I just haven't seen you spell that way
before my I you guys know how I spelled
my name the full Jacob
some people do some people don't
hello Bobby
let's go get the sacred is there a
sacreds here at this church up here I
think there is
no I will print
yeah j-a-k-o-b
a lot of people find that weird
Jacoby
or what'd you all call me Trey Jacob
Jacob
that was almost my YouTube Name by the
way
I almost chose my twitch and YouTube
handle to be Jacob so y-a-k-o-b
but I like ADT Jake
Jacoby mm-hmm
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna pronounce this
wrong as well Aaron
madeleaf
I say that right
made leaf
made a leaf
oh
is that like a different play on
Madeleine
made a leaf
I like that name
waiting for the Viagra only challenge
what would that be
just the biggest box sword in the world
in the entire game
oh it's in Netherlands okay I need to
start learning this stuff because I want
to move to
uh Europe at some point
it's a life goal of mine
Mada leaf
gosh
not a leaf
it's dutch for Daisy
gotcha that's cute
Viagra only challenge would be all
endurance
oh
oh we could try that run
I feel like I'd just constantly be
running
oh God yep I need to learn
I need to learn a new language
use the finger weapon okay
right guys
all endurance and use the longest spear
I'm glad you guys like these challenges
enough for me for to for you to come up
with other challenges as well
it's just funny
sorry for the boring setup at the
beginning here
hi Irby hi Finn
uh as an American it doesn't surprise me
that your dream is to live somewhere
that isn't America
yeah that's honestly been recent for me
I'd say up until I don't know
the last few years I'm like yeah I don't
really like it here
for the most part
I I already explained to you guys what
it was yesterday it's because I don't
want to have kids here that's literally
the one of the major reasons is I don't
want my kids to grow up here and I don't
want my kids to go to school here
you know I already went through all that
[ __ ] but
they haven't or they wouldn't
yeah I'm sure it is Trey I'll have to
be probably a big culture shock for a
while there
foreign do you expect any bosses to be a
real challenge
um I expect all of them to be somewhat
difficult
I don't know why they wouldn't be
hmm okay was there anything else like
any other tears down here I don't think
so let's go buy the
The Medallion
you don't want kids in general I do I've
all I've always wanted kids always I
don't know why
go forth ah I was interested tolerance
they don't ever want to go back
I have seen a lot of YouTubers uh move
to a different country
I wouldn't even say I'm like I don't
know a hundred thousand subscribers is a
really big deal
that I would say that's where you can
classify yourself as a YouTuber but I
just hit it so
you know what I mean
I I would classify my classify myself as
a YouTuber now
I can also let you a lot then why not I
am Carly
purchase
oh wait he doesn't have it
let me get the crafting kit
and the torch so you guys will shut up
about that
uh
wait where's The Medallion again
which one
is it is it the one by Alexander goodbye
what's Vigor only
exactly as it sounds
5000 IQ challenge only mined
God
it's a weeping Penance it's the one way
down here okay I was just there [ __ ]
the down Merchant
my first trip a prostitute asked me if
he wanted to come in and some dude asked
me if I wanted to buy a Coke I wanted to
buy coke
where was this
oh God
yeah 5000 IQ would be int
oh Amsterdam
So my aunt knuckle have like traveled
basically the whole world like they're
in um they're in Australia for the next
month and then they're gonna be in New
Zealand for another month but they've
gone to Amsterdam and they said it was
[ __ ] crazy there
like
exactly what you're saying like not
everything goes there and it's really
expensive
there's the lantern I gotta buy these
so it's the other one shoot okay not bad
but really really expensive
why were you at the hospital smoka
hope you're okay
oh it's a there's a merchant at Castle
morne
huh
hubby and I are going to Philippines
this July nice I'm going to Mexico
uh for my birthday in March I'm really
excited for that
I am really excited to go to Mexico
where's there a merchant other than that
guy chat
the one on the way oh just this one oh
okay got it
gotcha
Mexico
there it is got it
all right
that's all our runes
if I'm going to the US and meeting my
husband's family for the first time nice
that'll be fun
that'll be a good experience
donde esta Albania
so my parents have been to Mexico before
and my dad said you only need to know
two two phrases
donde esta el Bano
uh
and those cervezas por favor which is
two beers please
we're going to an all-inclusive
like you don't have to pay for Drakes
you don't gotta pay for food
those surveys of por favor
that bigger's not big not yet baby we
gotta go get the rooms my guy we gotta
go get the rooms
um I should go
there we go uh
I guess here
uh there's like a little town outside of
the resort but they don't let us go
anywhere other than that
it's we're basically just going to be in
the resort and that's it
can I even upgrade with this amount of
Rooney's no
uh
uh oh let me let me pop this bad boy on
course
I mean what do I do now do I go fight
Margaret
I don't know where to go
Pikachu
it's gonna be a day stream I always
stream at 10 A.M like 10 30 10 a.m CST
if only you could use your health bar as
a weapon
Rue dude plus three weapon first yeah
where can I get some runes really quick
trying to think
easy cave levels
yeah
I already went down into that cave
honestly I could [ __ ] farm this whole
area here real quick
eat ow
and I'm getting extra runes here no
that's not enough
the bird the ball and Caleb okay I don't
want to go to Caleb yet
no we don't want to go to the big
Dragon yet
uh I'm gonna go here
I'm gonna go
to this cave
the Eldon Beast drops fifty thousand
that's good to know they're 500 000.
do the trolls actually drop 10K okay I
want to go find out
because that'd be big
bad
is good to know angel
oh they dropped 1K
I mean that's a lot
can I even like fight these guys
Let's test it guys
now
it's kind of taking too long and for
did the other one see me uh-oh
foreign
was easier than this guy
dude these trolls were so inspired by
the ogre and Sakura
oh
I just want to see how many runes it
drops
what
the ball kidding how many was that
okay that was 1K
is Sakira worth playing the KIRO is one
of the best games ever made so yes
yes
1024
good good
excellent
okay that's all we can do for now
question is can we beat market like this
ah
I say we try
well where else could I go
um
swamp
I play on PC Astro
just get some bone yeah I could just not
go and fight Margaret
I already played bloodborne on stream we
played every single Souls game on stream
don't forget the level mind
you goober
we watched she beat Melania after six
hours we were glued to the TV
a lot of people enjoyed that I didn't
but a lot of people did so that makes me
happy
I do need to finish Demon Souls that's
true and Dark Souls 2. so I shouldn't
say all the games
shouldn't say all of them
you're right
it's not entirely accurate
uh that's scary Finn
you know what I don't want to fight him
at night I want to fight him during the
day
because it looks better to you guys
I'm That Kind of streamer I think about
y'all
think about y'all
oh chat
I didn't even tell you yet
you know that date I was supposed to go
on the other week and she canceled on me
we went on the date last night
and it was a good date
now I can't use any scar seals
we went on the date last night and it
was a good date
no she did not cancel again it was
actually a great time
I had a great time
emboldened by the flame of ambition
I thought you said you weren't coming
dad
that's a w right
did she whisper about the frost pots she
did not whisper about the frost pots
she did not
I was maintenance gotcha
future wife
first date guys first date
first date
W Riz
right
w rizz
foreign
wait my friend's dad asked her mom to
marry him on the first date almost at
their 50th anniversary
that's a different time
that's a different time
that is not worth it to do by the way
of blood must truly run in my veins
foreign
is always so confusing
also my date said that she did talk in
chat one time
[ __ ]
okay I'm gonna die
I don't know why
I don't think she's a member
why am I bad at dodging that right now
come on man
this guy this [ __ ] guy all right
that was a bad attempt
is your day watching now I don't know
she's at work
she works in it
we gotta make her a member
nah she don't want no attention
I want to use Roger but I also think I
don't have to
she's a big time gamer yeah
she loves games
plays a lot of Call of Duty right now
I thought he'd stagger there
probably here yep
how much damage does this do
328 that's probably worth it
[Music]
she plays stardew Valley
she plays OverWatch too
he plays Cod
um
she has not played Elden ring though
vowels of passing skin Warrior blood
must truly run in thy veins
tarnish okay
[ __ ] delay
her reasoning was she likes to play
games that she can play for 20 to 30
minutes like get in one match and be
done and then be like that's it
because she's she goes to work and
school
so she doesn't have time
which I think is fair
nice
this is going pretty good
see I tried to strafe there you saw it
he's kind of going cray-cray right now
[Music]
excellent
one more Bonk
not that bad not that bad
same age she's like three younger three
years younger than me
so pretty close
uh let's get some rizz in the chat rizz
rizz by the way a lot of rizz going on
here a lot of rizz rizz
I've been
testing you to see whether or not Grace
truly does like yeah
whether you are fit to face the
challenge that entails it seems my
worries were unfounded torrent had your
measure from the very start whereas I
merely pretended there is but one there
is I can do to offer you guidance where
did you get the Riz I don't know I don't
know I don't know where it went but it's
back
finally we can upgrade our Vigor by
Grace incredible
game journalist Elder ring is too hard
Gamers let's try more and more
ridiculous ways to beat the game exactly
very well
why is Melina measuring you it's above
average
right that's what she's measuring
you're kind of low on Vigor well I need
to kill things you get runes to never
mind
she's such a stereotypical female yeah
why was she testing me like that man
is this technically the Riz only run oh
my God
wow look at all that vigor
look at all that bigger chat that's
literally more than what we had before
laughs
in the uh other challenge
within some twos where else did I see
that
for my homegirl Molina
Mythic I'll make sure uh Molina gets
that
thank you
I'll make sure she gets that bro
thank you thank you
I knew it there it is
there is only run
can you show us some rizz rocky Lee
coaching content with Riz
I didn't even know you guys knew I was a
rocket league coach at one point
at 7 500 hours in rocket league for some
[ __ ] reason
I couldn't even tell you why
it is due
D level Vigor makes sense now
I saw you said that before the stream
started and I didn't understand what it
meant
would you still love me if you were an
omen I think I'd love you more
now that I know all your lore
where do I get the Bell bearings for all
this stuff
it's here right chat
oh also we can beat godric like this I'm
going I'm going I'm just going
we can beat godric like this
that's hella runes
and then we can go to that cave
yeah I think it's the crystalian cave
near
um it's like underneath the academy kind
of sort of
yeah yeah
Riley lucari Crystal tunnel yeah yeah
we have to go for serpent Hunter River I
think we have to
there
well but of course
guys which demigod do you think has the
most rizz
o
what a dumb question
we're done not ranala what an answer
not Renault
oh that's funny
because you know
that's good
okay radon radagon
why can't I jump up here man there we go
I think Michael is a good answer
that's literally like what he's about
right
Annie has a devoted cult
Godfrey has Unlimited rizz
true well what about when he got exiled
what did he do then
hmm
tell me that
um
what is Riz rizz is short for charisma
so you know you're like good on the
you're good at
talking I don't know what what do you
call it dude what is it
what is charisma you're just like you
know your cool cat you're a cool guy
people like you
right
Thea I think fear is just easy you can't
like
can I say that I think fia's just you
know she's easy to get like you know I
don't think that requires charisma
sorry
outgoing Pleasant personality okay there
we go
my Riz sucks at the gym
there you go
true
all right what the [ __ ] did drip say
what did he do
what the heck did drips do man
it's a gen Z term why am I saying it
then
I'm like a Generation X or a millennial
or whatever
I don't know what I am
I was born in 1995 what what does that
make me
he said you have no RIS
hey man I went on a date
and it went well
I think
when's your birthday March
all right
all right let's go
scum nuts chat degenerates are leaking
in dude you guys talked about scum nut
the other day and I went and checked
them out his chat is funny
true born air
is thy strength okay
this chat is funny bro
and he gets a lot of viewers for every
live stream I'm still trying to figure
out how to get more viewers I don't
really know how it works
dates
that's what I'm saying Crow thank you I
come like the stream chat
go ahead give it a like
the Lord of all that is golden
we have zero likes oh my God
let's do this
foreign
you're right
bog oh God
[Music]
I think I've mastered godric
now I talked so I'm gonna get [ __ ] up
somehow
we gotta watch this
nice Aaron
chat really wants scum nut to become a
femme boy that's interesting
scum nut was banned from twitch are you
serious like fully banned
I didn't know that truest of dragons
I always watch this bro need thy
strength
[Applause]
[Music]
I didn't get the cool part I'm sorry I
beat him up too quick
foreign
one of the coolest lines in gaming right
there
I'm an idiot
God damn it
all right
foreign
I was closer than I looked boys
that mist by the way
what map
oh I went into the hammer like a dumbass
foreign
and one day
we'll return together
to our home Chad who has more rizz
your boy has more rizz
clearly we just proved that
all right can't use great runes but it
is what it is it is what it is
GG
styling
I have no Ritz
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
very nice
let's do this
I did cut short his attack I think that
was lucky because I definitely could
have died there
drick has all there is why is he dead
then bro
actually is anything technically dead
not really
all right 37 bigger and we just beat
godric that's pretty impressive
do you have armor
all right someone become a member real
quick and I'll kill this guy Raven to
the Bone pushing me about our daily
member goal is looking bad boys
it's looking bad he back at you
one person become a member
right now I'll murder him filthy slug
feel it free lips feel my bloody wrath
what happens when you max out bigger
then we can no longer level
can no longer level man
all right
he lives
well never mind he dies five times now
he dies five times
let's go Peter
right
what's up
W's in the chat for Peter Brooks thank
you for coming to tarnish as well
thank you guys
you know I you know sometimes I gotta
sell out to get our memberships man I
gotta remind the chat that it exists
gotta remember bro
we also need to come up with a new idea
for 500 members
what I like I can do what I like there
you go baby now he's dead hello hello
dead
Peter you're a w
proxy or W as well thank you guys
are you going to use morgots or
radagon's rune
ratagon does not have a rune
uh
morgot does morgots great Rune only
increase your vigor
if it does I can
beat only run at 500 members are you
kidding me
beat only
feet
yes then I will use that great room
thousand percent
thousand percent
all right here's the thing chap if we
can get
two Reichard
then we're good
you know what I'm saying
however
getting past the godskin noble is going
to be quite the challenge
I it'll definitely be harder than
reichardt
trying to think of how we can do that
should I just upgrade the living [ __ ]
out of this club and just go at it
what is Commander nihil's foot weapon do
every button inverted
my brain would not be able to handle
that
sleep pots
all right how about this
how about this
500
oh I should go get that Miro
button randomizer that sounds
her 500 members do the kill most bosses
in two hours challenge
is that a challenge
is that a thing
we're at an hour 20 and I've killed
two it's not very good
no I have a torch
I can't equip a torch
level one level one run
that's what I was thinking
if we get to 500 members I say we we do
the the Rune level one challenge
I think that'll that might be weeks of
stream content if we do that by the way
weeks
but I say we do that
all bosses by Bosses blindfolded that's
unoriginal yeah it's still really
freaking hard though
everything is the fire Giant
you're trying oh man bro
that's funny
I have a I have a giant hatred for the
fire Giant
that's gonna break our computer
everything is malacath
holy [ __ ] that'd be insane
we'd get really good at malacath though
yeah we've done randomized
double Boss Mod would be extremely fun I
have said I think we should do that one
press one and chat if you want a double
boss so every enemy every character
every boss there's two of them
I think that would be that would be fun
I keep like
yeah press one if you want that
then maybe someday we can do three
one one one one one one one one all
right that's the goal then
500 members whenever we get there what
are we at 330 so we need literally 170
more that's a lot
and we will do the double Boss run
for now we're gonna do this should I
just go I think we should go to that uh
tunnel and get all the upgrades that we
can
I think that'll give us the most amount
of Riz
double boss randomizer I will think
about it being a randomizer as well
I'll think about it
I'll think about it
so double enemy double boss randomizer
I don't know if I've seen that
you get out of here sir
that horse was freaking out man
Lobos did it lately
I I ain't worried about doing challenges
that other people have done I still like
doing them they're fun
they're very very fun
I'll donate some more when I get robbing
banks and Lottery money in Minecraft you
guys never have to do anything by the
way I think if I make good content
people will become members and nobody
will have to gift anything
yeah I mean how about just 170 new
individual memberships that'd be cool
that'd be lit
whoa
but gifting helps a lot
speeds up the process
when do you plan on start making good
content are you kidding me
if I didn't make good content you
wouldn't be here just saying
you're here
you got time down
train having it bro not today
force them huh
I can't force people to do anything
that's a cool old Reaver guarantee huh
nice I'll take it man thanks
two players one character run one moves
the other attacks
um
I haven't seen it done before
you can time out people who aren't
members you mean are
we can time out ban anybody we want
also where's Joy
jump
I think she's completely asleep
hypnotize them to become a member
come one with the membership
become one become
a member become a part
of the green Club
you get it because you become green
get a green name I wish you guys could
have individual colors that you want
can I beat this dragon
no shot right
I'm gonna get the key and run away
yeah ain't no way bro no shot on no cap
on a stack
I am Melania it worked
laughs
it worked
thanks Trey
appreciate it man thank you for the five
those should start rolling out to people
if you get a gifted from Trey make sure
to say thank you
we like to see green in the chat and
green in our pockets [ __ ] yeah bro
your dog just walked behind you
there she is
there she is
oh
hello are you just super tired you don't
want to say hi
there's your head wait
how's your head Bubba
up come on don't roll come here
come in
come on
oh she she just went closer oh
my gosh oven King James
there she is hello hi Jake I'm so happy
to catch a stream this is perfect way to
decompress after shoveling snow for
whole evening greetings from Finland and
Baskin that glorious vigor
I will thank you very much for the 10
super chat
uh Katarina I had a cat
tarlina
I hope the shoveling snow went well
thank you very much
huh oh it's not open for you never mind
you can stay right there hello dude
she's so tired bro oh my God
she is so tired
hello who else became a member
Barry the Sade renewed their great room
thank you very much welcome back Trey
thank you again for the five and
Katarina
thank you for the 10 super chat that's
very kind
would you make her do I wanted to go up
here
come here
it's like she knows where the camera is
and doesn't want to be on camera man
she's so tired guys
can use that baby voice with us too
hi Chad oh Chad you're looking so cute
oh my God chat you're so cute
you like that are you into that I ever
had a God thanks for the Super Chat man
that's a so Joy's treat Fund in the
bottom right is a different link it
should be pinned at the top
uh if you want to do that all those go
to a different uh account and they go to
her treats
she's really tired guys please don't
please stop stop forever okay let's uh
let's continue then
I'm sorry
well you got you guys didn't like that
where is this place right here
way creepier than I thought it'd be how
is it different than where I talked to
my dog though it's not different
she's just asleep behind my chair
I feel gross now that
I thought you guys would get like you
would like it
I guess I was wrong
guess I was wrong man
feels bad
you are a good chat
you're not gonna wear armor or nothing
oh yeah I will definitely wear armor I
just haven't found armor yet
dog won't ask you to use Frost pot
that's why I love her
she hasn't asked me to use a frost pot
we should at some point do a a pot only
run
I feel like that would just be kind of
annoying though like constantly make
pots
not enough endurance for any decent
armor
you're not wrong if that becomes a
problem then we'll definitely have to do
something else
just take damage with your chest hair I
do have chest hair as you can see I also
have back hair leg hair and ass hair
we're farming materials right now though
deathbed dress would go perfect with
your hair
dude true dude that would work because
she takes your she takes your vigor via
does
well now we have to do her whole thing
there's a somber later when we need it
there's a somber three we got the one
the two the three
where can I pick up a four like randomly
I know I can buy it from EG but is there
anything on the ground
it could be a four in here for all I
know I don't know
I don't know nothing
what's your favorite Pokemon type I have
never
watched Pokemon or played Pokemon
ever
now I'm probably gonna get yelled at for
that I just haven't
I thought it was weird
I thought it was weird bro
[Music]
I already got the three
foreign
excellent
nice Aaron
it's even harder to get into as an adult
yeah I just didn't I didn't watch it as
a kid either
oh there's another two
yeah the bigger check just passed huh
laughs
so that's nice it's gonna be hard to
kill us
uh until probably the end game then
everything just scales
but yeah I watched Yu-Gi-Oh
Yu-Gi-Oh is cool
not So Much Anymore
it was
for 500 members post your home address
as a prank
that's not a prank that's just dumb
foreign
that's just kind of stupid
yeah let's not do that
yep one two three four leg my balls Lane
that's my that's my address chat it's my
address
nope I don't do DND at all no DND
I want weapon shreds dude
I have to get boobs
uh that sounds like a quick way to get
canceled
you want some maid outfit stream where
did that happen
what
Arroyo Lane where do I know that from
did I already go in here
yeah
d d is Dungeons and Dragons
right that's Breaking Bad
that was their address right
1800 eat my yep there it is
can you please make it only fans I said
it 5 000 members
so y'all better tell your friends I'm
streaming Bro
you all want this here comes
up there you go I love how the
memberships just roll out randomly
throughout the Stream
2000 how about we focus on getting to
500 because that seems Out Of Reach to
be honest with you
like right now 500 members legitimately
seems Out Of Reach
so
one thing at a time
one thing at a time
this place is big
damn
you'll be there before you're ready for
it
500 members
I don't know
we'll have to see
okay we got a blunt weapon and
everything this should be pretty good
yeah I love sakiro man I have like a
thousand hours in sakuro I absolutely
love that game
it's a GG
how many hours in Eldon ring uh I'm
getting up on
800 I think
now if you count all the editing time
probably a couple thousand
probably a couple thousand
okay we got that now we're gonna go get
our physic where's my dog
guys she left
she's on the chair look
Joy
there she is hi baby
you want to go on the porch
and go on porch
look how she knows what I meant
look at that look how smart she is
you see that she know exactly what I
meant there
isn't that crazy
what kind of breed is that so she's a
German Shepherd Golden Retriever mix
very smart dog
only run
we'll teach Joy how to play and she can
go crazy
okay almost died there
800 hours that's weak well that's of me
just playing the game I'm talking
recording and editing is probably I
would say close to 2 000 hours something
like that
uh okay let's go get our physic and
stuff
oh nope
she was barking
definitely don't want her to just be out
there barking her head off
[Music]
let me make it daytime so you guys can
actually see
nothing wrong with dumb dogs they're
very entertaining
no you're right
true
would you recommend streaming uh I don't
know depends on what you want to do
I have fun with it so I do it
I'd rather dump 2K hours
and to see us go to learn Russian
what a sentence
laxative Speed Run see if you can beat
Elden ring before you [ __ ] yourself
I feel like that would just be an insta
ban right like that'd just be an insta
ban
by uh for YouTube there
hello
I stream Dark Souls one a while back I
want to get back into it but I can't for
some reason
well you gotta figure out why
why didn't you like it
was
no strip run oh God
I would be so careful
okay don't need that
okay
your German Shepherd taught itself how
to open all the doors in the house
Joy definitely knows how to open doors
she just kind of doesn't sometimes
thank you
behold dog
a skin walker for a pet what
I love Dark Souls 3 man
what's your favorite food Jake
so this might be super basic
but my favorite meal
that I can possibly eat like if I were
on my deathbed
or it was like my last meal
I would literally choose to have a
cheeseburger and french fries
that's what I want
that is my favorite meal
such a basic boring and uninteresting
human
okay
drips have you turned into a hate
Watcher or something
your Vibe is flipped but I think you're
also kidding
at what restaurant
yeah that that's definitely important
based
if your date is smart she'll watch these
streams and know everything about you no
she does she literally watches the
streams dude
does watch the streams
Five Guys is so over overpriced it's
insane
it's so overpriced
they're good
but
insanely expensive here
um so I got my physic
wasn't super important to get that but
let's go back here upgrade as much as we
can
not like a type of cheeseburger American
cheese
honestly probably a double
like a double cheeseburger
I'm good
I'm good bro
I know it's basic it is what it is
I'm extremely unstable tomorrow I will
be horny got it
so Maya this sounds so like privileged
but my favorite burger I've ever had
my parents took me to a winery
and they had this bacon onion
cheeseburger
with a side of french fries and a side
of mac and cheese
that was my favorite meal I have ever
had
it was so incredibly good I I couldn't
believe how good it was
it was insane
where do I get uh smithing Stone threes
chat
where do I get them
I'll swing by and grab it
I don't know what dad's talking about
here
it was so good
side of mac and it was like the
creamiest mac and [ __ ] like white white
cheddar mac and cheese bro
I'm thinking about it right now and I'm
I'm
I'm surprised the desk didn't you never
mind
it's Altus Plateau that's what I thought
is it like through this area
uh it would be over here kinda
Also let's level our vigor
yeah white cheddar mac and cheese bro I
I'm
also you guys think we can beat Ronaldo
I mean we won't say yeah we can beat the
[ __ ] out of Ronaldo actually
we can also get to alter splato
and get another fizzy okay I I have a
thing on my brain
the academy has a good number of
smithing threes does it really
no wait there's threes over here
you'll give her the rizz
that was one of the funniest things I've
heard in chat with someone's like well
Ronaldo doesn't have any risk foreign
like just as a lore geek that was so
[ __ ] funny
I was like dude Savage
oh those are twos well I did grab the
threes up there
you beat anyone with enough alcohol in
here
are you guys surprised with how far I
got
well Ronaldo's a great boss cat I'm just
saying like the RIS the Charisma thing
where she was literally left by her
husband for another guy that sucks
that sucks man yeah I only can level up
bigger it's a very basic challenge
I think renal is great I think she's an
awesome boss
was I gonna do something else
oh yeah I have to go in here though
you gave up alcohol nice dude
I had a couple beers on my date last
night
she had a couple beers too she actually
drank more than I did
buy like half a beer or whatever
so it wasn't a lot
ranala is not the wizard
you ever do a boss to your list uh yeah
I did it's on the channel from you know
nine months ago
I don't think it's changed I think I
think my opinion is still the same
girls do we're just modest
about what
drinking
I rarely drink but when I do it shots
right
melania's at the bottom
what do you think I gave Melania guys
on the tier list if you haven't seen it
yet
what do you think I gave Melania
s tier is the best it goes s a b b f I
think
something like that you guys know what a
terrorist is
foreign
agreed cat to be honest
and I've only gotten like second hand
I've never actually smoked weed but I
think I'd rather smoke weed than drink
be
I gave her a d or no no I'm sorry I gave
Melania a b not a d
ude that sounded bad uh yeah I gave her
a b
I think most things about Millennia are
great
however I do I just don't like fighting
her and I never have
I put godric at an s
game of big fat ass
I think godric's one of the coolest
bosses in gaming
however he is very easy but that wasn't
the entire point of the tier list
salty sure
it's the only thing people who love
Melania say when I say I don't like
Melania
you're just salty
totally
I I think I gave Mogan a or an s
if I were to remake the tier list I
would give Mogan S I think he is
[ __ ] perfect
all right let's see if we can beat
Ronaldo now
this one I just want to get to that spot
you should rate their Riz
you know that'd be good for the the the
Gen Z's you think they'd get a lot of
views from the young audience
honestly I really don't want a young
audience
I really don't want it
yeah she's good
uh I gave Reichard an S I'm pretty sure
I think reichard's an s
um Melania a b I'm trying to think of
all the bosses
I guess if I would rate them now I would
rate Margaret in A godric and S
ranala
like a b or an A
buyer giant is an F
Regal ancestor spirit I would give an a
maybe even a b
might be brought up to an a just for the
music Alone
um Godfrey and hor well godfreys and S
and horalu is an a
for me
radagon is an S eldenbeast is a d
well this is my new list that list was
from however long ago
what other bosses am I missing in my
head
I put MOG at an s
I'd give malacath an s
at this point
I think malikath kicks ass
um Gideon's like a [ __ ]
C or a d
why is this dog still here bro
oh my God
look at it just backing up because it's
not supposed to be here
let me get up here
oh it's a somber
rig
red wolf and radagon I'd give like a c
or a d
ude
this guy's strong
oh I'm one-handing
can't believe it
thank you
I'd give Gideon like a a d maybe a c
he seems misplaced to be honest what
he can do that that was sick
this guy's a beast
foreign
Ty
of the halog tree halog tree
um
647 runes for that that's not worth it
I'd give Loretta like an a why is that
so far away
I jumped and was just surprised I'm just
like what
I was just surprised
[Laughter]
oh my God
so my dad is an art teacher chat to
change the subject for me falling to my
death of course
my dad's an art teacher high school art
teacher he is retiring after this
semester is over in June May June
he's giving me a countdown he said 86
days left every day he says 87 86. he
does the countdown and he has a white
board in the kitchen
and it says days left and it's just the
countdown to the last day when he can
retire he's so excited
so excited bro
I've never seen anyone fight Gideon more
than a few seconds
okay so you probably didn't know this
then
Gideon got a buff and he's kind of
insane now
but I don't rate the bosses just based
on difficulty I think a lot goes into it
to a boss being uh on a higher on the
tier list
did I miss any bosses like main bosses I
don't think so
nice
look at look at all this [ __ ] in my body
I love it
yeah Gideon's a [ __ ] Shad now
where are my runes gonna be at
okay wait he's back
he responds
interesting
okay sick
I took an arrow to the back of the knee
I took an arrow to the knee
now I wasn't eventually like [ __ ] [ __ ]
me I can't even think right now okay
did anyone enjoy crucifix of the Mad
King from Dark Souls 3. is that a weapon
enemy's kind of a pain yeah we're
getting through it
spectacle lore music mechanical
complexity Aesthetics of the boss matter
hence Gail tops it for me Gail is
probably a top three boss of all time in
my opinion definitely
probably top three ever for sure
foreign
good thing our vigor's insane
favorite boss in Alvin ring we're done
is he not staggered
I answered my own question
hi Christian
excellent
zpz baby
it just is that easy
your Vigor checking bosses
dude 41 Vigor at this point is kind of
nuts actually
why is the club so good I mean we
upgraded it a lot we have we've actually
barely upgraded it I'm curious of how
this weapon is fully upgraded
we're only in like this the smithing
threes
you guys said there's a lot in this area
but I'm not I don't know about that
are these smithing threes no
this challenge is going better listen
we're in the early game
all right we got it we gotta do it on
him boys
we gotta to it we gotta do it to this
prick
okay either he disappeared
like he'll just literally be gone oh
wait he's uh right above me what the
heck
you see him
you see him
wait
what the heck
okay bye
what the heck bro
what the heck dude
all right
bye
all right let's get our toes nibbled by
on by a kid
and skip
not worth
really really there we go
move
foreign
this is gonna suck without bleed or
anything
wrong button
comes
people
and then
the ash of War kind of sucks we might
want to change that up
we should get a different ashawar
for sure for sure
sleep time
I like how each kid has a different
voice actor you guys notice that they're
not each one but the
you know what I mean there's like a few
different ones
the same one but they
[Music]
put sword dance on the club I don't know
what we'll have to go check it out
how are you making different tack strips
it's kind of cool
don't you need a better weapon I mean
does it look like it
I hate it here
no I wanted to bring
foreign
[Music]
I just realized I'm still naked
go to her
okay
dude you just did that okay
she's getting real spammy dude
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
no we can wait
foreign
[Music]
where's our health at Chad where is he I
don't even see it
it's it's not on the screen
oh we're summoning again huh okay
what's new how many times did she
[ __ ] summoned
she's going for the dream
now she's dead
what the heck bro
that was a lot of spam for whatever
reason
was there a pixel
uh that was easy stuff Chad that was
[ __ ] easy bro she's not hard at all
bro
not hard at all bro
I have a question chat let me let me let
me take a look here let me take a look
ski
uh we're not even at 200 likes yet I
need you all to like the stream right
now I'm dead I said it I'm plugging it
in there like the stream it's literally
the only way to grow a stream
it's the only way
so make sure you do it thank you I also
have uh Photoshop open
for no reason there we go that probably
helps a lot
height
you need one shot radon
I doubt it
my sweetings
like the Stream
did we get to 200 all right there it is
thank you guys thank you
then that's big
it's always the goal every stream
to be better born a new
to be better born a new
you can't say that look at your health
bar I'm just saying she didn't have any
health
I didn't see it
where the two dislikes come from
probably hate Watchers
yeah it is what it is
what should we do now chat what should
we do now
let's go see if we can upgrade
where did he flee my sweetings come out
from whence he hide what was that
where did he feed I'm trying to go to
the Round Table
okay
interesting
go dunk on the draconic tree sentinel oh
I didn't I'll be doing well just lay out
I could dunk on him you think
can any can any of you guys in chat dunk
I'm five foot nine so that's already an
automatic no
the frick
somber threes
Roger has a gift for you
I don't need anything from Roger I'm
five nine and white it's so right same
here
same here dude
holy oh fine
there we go
you spelled common correctly how could
you
I'm 6'4 can't touch rim
nice
all right where where do I get uh
smithing Stone threes
was it really just Altus plateau
I literally only need like three more
hmm
we already went in there that gives us
saw or gives us smithing one and two uh
the bell for that by the way
buy them from EG we don't need sombers
we need normal
how's Joy she's on the porch right here
I think she wants to come in she's
facing the other way
we both
nope
no ball
s
here you go okay
what are you doing
yep she's all good
thanks so much for the free fake picks
you're welcome
you're welcome man
she gets so camera shy do you know where
the camera is you know what it is
at 12 30 when did I start at 10 30 took
her out right before then you're okay
we'll wait till one all right
gotta give her all the love and
attention Academy rooftops have some
threes
oh
are they easy to get
she likes to go into the bedroom mom if
you're still in chat by the way
she likes to lay on the bed and just
look straight out the window or she
likes to be on the porch and then I put
her bed right here
next to the window on the porch and she
likes to lay there too
she's been up here a few times she likes
up here but I keep the window closed
because it gets really really bright on
the camera
but then after I'm done
Trey just sent me a picture of feet
excellent all right
eight total will be found throughout
right kind of tunnel yellow colored
stones on the walls three in the gazebo
with the Statue South East
three in a gazebo with a statue
south east of Academy Town side of Grace
I think I already got that one
I think I already got that
gazebos in leernia
I can look for more gazebos because we
literally just need three more then
we're then we're golden
yeah where is that Bell bearing trap do
you know where that is where I get
reason force with the Bell bearing
where is that
but I'll look for some gazebos I already
went in that gazebo and got the threes
there
[ __ ] that guy in particular
South once you pass the Double Tree
Sentinel so Altus plateau
sealed tunnel sealed cave
gotcha
thank you chat seal tunnel in Altus got
it
is that the yeah it's right after the
Doubletree Sentinel
I know exactly what you're talking about
we could get the dectus medallions and
literally just go straight there
thoughts
wait where does this take me
that takes me up there doesn't it just
to the same thing
I say we get the dectus medallions and
just go get that I think we'll we'll do
less time doing that to be honest with
you
uh yep let's do it
double crystalian boss
well then that's not the one I'm
thinking of
now I'm confused
oh that takes you to EG
yeah double crocheting gives the somber
one
the one cave that I'm thinking of has
the uh
the AL bastard Lord and it leads to
reichard's Divine Tower like the it's
kind of hidden
you know what I mean
but there's also like an entire cave
system before all that
bye
that's the one that's what I thought
okay
I was watching your random Rune run and
then realize you are streaming that's
good Jay
I'm gonna be streaming a lot chat so
hopefully you're ready for that because
I have no
uh
I don't have any inspiration for lore
videos right now
we need new content man or something
will come along where it's like oh I
should make a video on that and then I
will but I just don't have anything like
that right now I have to I have to be in
the the mindset and the mood to do so
I might make a cinematic video on
Millicent's questline
I think that would be really cool
but that also takes a ton of time
so
I just wouldn't be streaming if I was
making that
make your own lore already did
Rick video baby
we tried mortal shell not yet
I've had a lot of requests to though
um
I also need to go to the grocery store
today
lore on the dogs and birds
I'm good personally
I'm sure plenty of people out there have
already done it I'm Vigor checking this
guy so hard right now holy [ __ ]
okay let's go to the war Master Shack
real quick and see what we can put on
this
that could be a bit better
I think he has some cool stuff
what should I put on this chat we've got
the stamp or the Stomp the kick endure
war cry
I think spinning slash is kind of what
we have on it already
Harry
impaling thrust
I don't think we can put bloody slash on
the club now
the ad was selling tickets to Les
Miserables at the Fox Theater
that's good that's a good ad right
that's good mom
storm blade guys
here
no I don't want to do storm blade
what does endure do
this ash War grants an Armament the
heavy Affinity of the following skill
damage taken while using this skill is
reduced
that seems pretty good
about work we already have war cry right
spinning slash isn't stomp good
swords axes and hammers
is my club considered a hammer
I already had barbaric Roar
these are all kind of mid
you guys got to remember I can't upgrade
anything so there's lots of weapons that
I literally can't use
clubs are hammers
hold on well
I think this should be good
I'm sticking with the club man I'm
invested in the club until we get the
serpent Hunter obviously
then that will take precedent
s lay out your own God should trap
heavy
it just changes the scaling
should I make it heavy chat
the scaling doesn't matter since I can't
upgrade strength
you're naked thank you thank you for
telling me this
might as well
and then we have that
okay
now let's go get the other medallion
over ha over her okay
we improve Studio mobile I noticed that
I noticed that
recommend the turtle Shield does that
increase my stamina
if so I can't use it
yeah I was just thinking that print
we'll see the difference
wait
yeah this is the better Asher board
definitely
dang
all right
all right all right okay okay
I don't know why I did that
honestly I did it for fun
where am I going this way
this way
oh you want me to use two sticks
hmm
would that be too much
what up Mythic
it's stamina recovery only
oh you're right so it doesn't increase
my stamina but I could use it
is that the same for the turtle Talisman
chat like it doesn't actually just
increase my my stat
so we probably could get that
and get the turtle shell if it doesn't
make me fat roll because remember we
can't upgrade
while we can use the turtle Talisman to
wear it potentially
we should do that
that'll be our next order of business
oh God
this hoe [ __ ]
what requires 14 strength all we want to
use it for is the buff that's it
we don't actually need to wield it per
se
I just say per se it's weird
[Laughter]
wow
oh my God why is she
so [ __ ] hard
there we go
Miss sacred scorpion charm again don't
need this anymore raise this holy attack
nope
go speak Turtle Pope learn the ways of
true Vigor is that a thing
does he do that
I don't remember Turtle Pope doing
anything like that
you ever just hit a moment in this game
like certain time of day certain weather
certain area and you're just like damn
there are some people that think this
game is ugly
there are people out there that exist
that think Eldon ring is ugly and
I I don't know what's wrong with them
this game is so pretty bro
Game of the Year by the way
and it won art Direction
art Direction by the way
oh I need the stone sword keys do I have
one I I do
[Music]
okay y'all need to remind me to drink
water
I didn't even refill mine from yesterday
I've been bad about water the last
couple days
I heard someone say it looks like it's
from 2010. that's [ __ ] nuts bro
that is weird
okay now we go get
the turtle shield and see if we can
actually use it
not use it but at least have it on on
our back without fat rolling
which that Talisman should actually help
with that
nice
okay
that's fine and then dual wield
nice
did you go on the date dehydrated
probably
and then I had two beers with her
okay
okay
it's coming along chat now what do we do
I'm thinking
currently thinking
in my head thinking
go turn green at ranala hell no
I'm red
look at this man
we want to uh just to like a bar
well not a bar it was like a it was a
it's called Corner Pub
they have really good food there
I got a chicken wrap
with fries and she got a chicken
sandwich
both were very good
why do you all want me to wear pants
you think I'm gonna get demonetized for
my character not wearing pants
oh yeah we wanted to go to Caleb
that's right
I just realize your character's male I
am Melania
blade of Nicola whoa Anonymous with the
15 donation the Joy's treat fund
I appreciate that thank you I don't know
who you are
but that goes to the treats as you guys
can see bottom right
it's also pinned at the top of the chat
by the way it's the pin message in the
chat it's a different link entirely
if anyone wants to help out with Jojo
her and I appreciate it
bet it's the girl from the date Maybe
maybe maybe actually
that's possible
wanna see us go skin I don't have money
dude to sell it
isn't that what you do with cs go Skins
also is there anywhere in caled that has
uh smithing Stone threes
and force
trying to think
also I kind of bet we could beat redone
like this
I'm not terrified of radon
hmm
Stalin cave
where Alexander is sometimes
rodan's soldiers drop it okay I'll make
sure to go on the cave after I get the
dectus here
because we want to get to Altus anyway
Gale tunnel has fours and then radon
soldiers drop threes okay
foreign
we could go underground for those as
well that's true
good point
[Music]
well thank you again Anonymous that is
very helpful
I don't know who you are
well Joy's gonna be eating good
foreign
just for the smithing stone or the
Serpent's Hunter sword later
God damn it
this would probably be easier off
torrent but here I am not doing it
there we go
let's go get the not well do I want to
go down here yet
um
did I get that right there
I did I'm cool with it
what ending are you going for whatever
chat wants me to do by the end
it's usually what I do
nice [ __ ]
oh I can't just go up this way sick
dung eater ending
I think we should do fia's ending
because she has like something to do
with Vigor somewhat
age
imagine a weapon that scales with bigger
I think I think I said this earlier but
I'm surprised the Blasphemous blade
doesn't scale with a bigger
because it increases your health when
you use the Asher board
and hit somebody
you know what I'm saying
chat whenever you go to the grocery
store what's like the main thing you
always remember to get like what's your
favorite thing
what's your favorite snack or food I
think that's a better question what's
your favorite snack or food to eat
foreign
bro
you bulking my guy
coffee
right
bread
cheese
Takis Ruffles chips
Cheez-Its
monster Hydro I haven't had those I've
had Cheez-Its but not monster Hydro
okay we're good there
we go and I think I already got two
dectus
which is helpful yep there we go and now
we're there
milk I drink that by the leader dude I
drink a lot of milk as well you know it
was
weird
and maybe someone's smarter than myself
can unders Maybe
tell me why this is so
for I would say about a year last year I
barely drank milk
I when I was a kid I used to like
literally pour multiple glasses of milk
and just drink them because I like milk
right
but all of like probably a year and a
half ago for an entire year I just like
barely drank any milk and I noticed like
during that time I was tired all the
time I didn't have any energy
uh had a lot of headaches for no reason
as well and then all of a sudden I
started drinking milk again and all of
that went away
like I don't feel the need to take naps
during the day at all like I have energy
from when I wake up until I go to bed
all that stuff bro
I wonder why
you think it was a Calcium deficiency
because that's the only realistic answer
that I can think of
I don't know if milk D hydrates you or
hydrates you
I love milk though milk is great
because I drank a lot of water during
the time that I didn't drink milk but
then I started drinking milk along with
water
I for me it's Gotta either be a Calcium
deficiency
or a vitamin D deficiency that made me
tired or grocky without drinking it
I don't know
I hate cow milk cheese yogurt all good
but milk no veggie milk is okay though
yeah I know it doesn't float the bow to
some people
I drink milk directly from the cow get
on my level
foreign
I just needed a better gaming chair
that's what it was it was the gaming
chair issue
right
well yeah it hydrates you but I didn't
think that was the problem
thank you man milk is key to bulk it is
so I the reason I stopped drinking milk
was because I was trying to lose weight
and I heard
probably from some Andrew Tate Tick Tock
or whatever that it was like drink less
milk
you lose weight and I did lose a lot of
weight
because I like I've said this before I
was 220 I was close to 225
uh at five nine which is you know
overweight
um back in 2019
and now I'm at like 180.
so I've lost a lot of weight
but
I like milk man
I'm gonna drink my milk bro
do you have any smithing threes sir
oh come on
where do I want to go okay let's go back
this way
he had a little bit too much Vigor facts
got milk would you consider a character
theme to build I'm considering doing a
Bowser build within with Crucible
incants and a dragon claw that sounds
cool man
you should do that
I haven't considered it but that does
sound cool
I am the Milkman my milk is delicious
one of the weirdest memes ever
I've ever seen
I am the Milkman my milk is delicious
he did have clothes
I can also get a stamina medallion
well wait does that increase my
attributes chat
with a medallion
from Margaret here
foreign
it just increases Max stamina that's it
hmm I'll take a look at it
less milk less weight less vigor
best phase one osc and Elden ring
let's say the godskins have the best
yeah I can Assassin's Creed I just
haven't found anything yet
see how we're doing here
foreign
not good
that's good
why are we doing no damage to him right
now
foreign
oh my God I hate you
foreign
strike negation
this is gonna take forever
I'm not really understanding the damage
output here though
two sacred tears and Altus could be
helpful yeah you're right
foreign
it's not worth it to do that
Jesus
God I was just a baseball right there
dude I'm nuts
that reached my face apparently
this ain't even worth it is it guys
it's really not
that delay was so insane
I didn't put anything in my physic did I
no no
I have to be really careful
[ __ ] just do that again
I didn't put anything in my physic yet I
thought I did
play distance we want the two this is
good too
let's go
nice
so does this
[ __ ] around
it just increases my stamina and doesn't
mess with the the thingies oh and it
stacks that's big that that was worth
that was worth for sure
what's your Vigor at
currently we are at 49. we're about to
be a bit higher as well
that was a w though good good stuff Chad
good stuff
so where are the sacred tears here
there's one I know I know where one is
let's level that Vigor even more we got
to get to 99 probably as soon as we can
51.
good
um
one is
wait
I need to go back over here anyway
I didn't grab this chat
new trailer for season four part three
Attack on Titan dropped oh [ __ ] I need
to watch that later
malachath perfect gameplay wise easy
best boss right I think malakath is one
of the best yeah
I didn't grab this chat I'm a dumbass
idiot
stupid poo poo head that's what I am
I I do like Attack on Titan
I'll have to watch that later
um okay so let me get down here guys
[ __ ] Trey sending me feet what was
that
you're alive
I thought he died after Margaret uses
his body interesting
I need to let joy out to go pee pee
Joy do you want to go pee
uh oh here she comes here's her face
hello
stay
look at this
you need to go pee
yeah
okay we'll be right back chat we gotta
go pee
I think I'm safe here
do you need to go
oh my goodness look at his tail holy
tail
okay
I did that on purpose just so you know
all right thank you
okay
what up chat
you can use Morningstar I don't think I
have enough strength or decks for it
why are y'all saying gur Greer what
let's all start saying Greer he will be
confused caught ya
idiots
that hurt
wait
Joy what are you doing
oh she's got her water
my son told me to do it okay buddy
okay buddy here's the church where you
fight Eleanor yep the other is south of
the sainted hero's Grave Just Northwest
tip of the great walkway
right okay I'm going down in here though
yep Joy's the final boss
she's so cute that nobody can fight her
which is why she's so hard to beat
all right guys
all right guys
notes
did you do the Euro Quest no
I have many a Time
but not right now
all the tears are under America's tits
you're not wrong
well some are under ratagon
same thing
Joy do you want to lay on the porch
okay no barking
win serpent Hunter we're getting there
man we're getting there
you get a fire giant to get church here
what no you don't
okay that's what we wanted
are there any others down here though
oh
fives okay I mean that'll be good later
you need to get to fire giant to get
churched here or Euro Quest
you do
no you don't
you there's just the church on the way
to the fire Giant
you think reichardt could be the
eldenbeast I have no idea
I think Reichard would be like too lazy
I need to throw that at the wall
I can't tell if he's talking about the
sacred tears or not
wait
[Music]
fives are gonna be good later
Reichard versus placidusax I don't I
don't know
I put a lot of money on Reichard for a
lot of stuff considering we have to
gimmick fight him to beat him
your vigor's too low okay I'll I'm
getting on that man promise
I'm on it uh oh okay I thought I did
didn't though
nice trap idiot didn't get me though
yeah I'm not sure what they're referring
to
when they're talking about a tear or the
fire Giant
oh whoops I don't have the roar anymore
I'm stupid
this might be hard
I can't even hit him
testing out a stagger testing out a
stagger
foreign
that's good how much damage we're doing
here 17 by the way
what the heck man
okay
damn
monster
yeah we're definitely going to use more
God's great room for sure
it is one of those dick posts right here
I never know what they're for
uh with the fully upgraded serpent
Hunter
I don't know Dylan
and he staggered the one time and now
he's just like you don't give a [ __ ]
all right
a lot of people missed this boss and
this entire Divine Tower
this is the way to reichardt's Divine
Tower
how
okay I ran to the side one time and it
didn't hit me but now it's hit me
consistently
foreign
this guy's a beast
there we go
you have access Europe from the
beginning of the game just depends on if
you killed yeah I know we're not talking
about Euro's Quest I'm just like someone
said you get
a [ __ ] sacred tear by the fire giant
only if you do something with Euro which
I don't think is a thing
unless I've just never seen that before
nice
oh she's asleep she's asleep what up
Brent how are you okay
so we got what we wanted now we peace
before I let chaos take the world I
killed every NPC hell yeah bro
um it's theorized that well it's not
theorized it's in the description
somewhere the Onyx Lords did teach uh
radon gravity magic and felia
uh well [ __ ] I have to turn those in I
need to
smithing Stone threes two
are you allowed to change acid War yeah
yeah yeah I didn't really get to use
them on that one to be honest he was too
quick to even use that attack
one
fours do I have before I run all the way
over there
zero so how many do we need twelve
oh my God
12 right
total to go through all of four
is that
how many
your lore videos challenge vati thanks
I'm glad you think so
I can only buy seven
oh I only have the amount of runes for
that that's fine
I have more
thanks Bobby
am I too late you're never late
never ever late
you can't be late two plus four plus six
so twelve
um yep
five
is Vigor 60 not quite we're at a 52.
52.
yep never late to like the video chat if
you haven't liked the video yet go ahead
and make sure to like the stream video
Etc same thing right same thing
make sure to like it I'd appreciate it
if you did
[Music]
oops sorry
there we go
okay
okay
see if we can actually buy more I'm not
sure oh yeah we needed five right can
only buy four
eat
[Music]
without leveling strength club and
serpent Hunter is only a 48 difference
like 48 total well what if we upgrade it
all the way I know it scales with
strength as well
it's probably the best bet that we have
you know
I need to buy the one more
you've missed lots of upgrading Vigor
how do I miss it
please no sir Don you're being weird
what's going on bro
what's going on man what the [ __ ] dude I
hate that I have to run back and forth
here
300 likes would be crazy
you've ever had that many
sure
sure sure
I don't need smithing Stone ones anymore
should be enough
do AI glitch on Noble you can't they
patch that
I wish I could though
but they did patch it
either one more investing only in
vinegar only brings you so far you
should put points and vigor instead yeah
exactly
hopefully less coaching today God I hope
so
yesterday was like probably the worst
dream I've ever had
personally but it is what it is all
right that's probably pretty good
all right
where are we going
I think we should fight radon definitely
I think radon is the next step here
for sure
she was getting heated dude it was just
I was annoyed
I was annoyed Roost then roon roulette
it never felt serious the last two
streams with the intelligence build
it was like if I didn't do exactly what
these people told me to do they would
just get [ __ ] pissed
it was so annoying
now I'm just going the wrong way
I like just ran in a direction for some
reason
hmm
there it is oh
can I jump that over there
I'm going over here
yeah you can definitely see the
difference it
streaming is such
um it's such
Vibe oriented does that make sense
it all depends on a Vibe and if like the
chat can tell when I'm not having fun
and then they have less fun
and I don't know it wasn't even that
much of chat who were um
there's a four
damn
it wasn't even that much a chat there
was just enough of them to where it was
just like oh my God shut up
foreign
and then they'd get mad at me for
telling them to shut up so
that's that's when I break is when
people get mad when I call them out for
being annoying
yeah I would say it was probably like 20
people
who are never here usually
just came out of the woodwork and just
made the stream just so bad
what are you
what were they saying they just wanted
me to perfect
my intelligence build for some reason
instead of just letting me play with
what I had
like we were doing a wizard build and
they wanted me to mid-max the entire
build the entire [ __ ] time it was so
annoying so let me play
they just get pissed when I wouldn't
he kept talking about Moon sorceries and
I'm like I don't really like Moon
sorceries they take too long to use and
then they would just keep telling me to
use Moon sorceries I just I don't know
it just was non-fucking stop dude
and then I'd call him out for being
annoying and then they would call me an
[ __ ] I'm like I'm sorry I don't suck
my chat's dick
like constantly dude I and I think
people realize that and appreciate that
because there are a lot of streamers out
there I don't know how many streams you
guys watch
there are a lot of streamers out there
where they will like streamers will lie
and [ __ ] uh like
just suck the chat's dick to get you
know I don't I don't know but I just
can't do that personally I just can't I
should buy these clothes
I don't have any money I'll come back if
I want
foreign
yeah that's what I'm saying I I don't
know why they couldn't just let me play
but
it is what it is and it's like if I
didn't do it in the exact order that
they wanted in the in at the exact time
uh they get mad and I just wasn't having
a lot of fun with it
so I stopped
and then I went on a date with a girl
and I had a great time
so my day went from bad to just
instantly good
so it wasn't that big of a deal
do you like guides for chat what does
that mean
but have you heard about Moon sorceries
uh-huh
sure have heard of it
W date
either try too hard to be funny or
they're really [ __ ] to chat
but Jake Jake is a gamer yeah I I don't
know
I don't know man it is what it is I'm
not really pressed about it anymore
yesterday I just needed to get off
because I just wasn't having fun
and that was probably the best choice I
could have done
Champions welcome
Champions
welcome ruin's Greatsword is my favorite
build
[Music]
we're watching this
I'm also going to make another coffee
real quick I'll be right back allow me
to paint you the full picture
General radon is cursed ever to wander
foreign
[Music]
howling at the sky
but now
we must make Merry oh Gathering of
Champions the rebels begin
the celebration of War
the radon Festival
[Music]
foreign
foreign
letting that coffee sit for a minute
I also got a snack
why did godric graft a horsey onto his
body
so he could run faster
Trey what did you just say
and do you mean redone
and it's not grafted
he hovers above it with gravity Magic
interesting
try Moon sorceries
your favorite kind of coffee I use these
uh K-Cups that are uh Dunkin Donuts
they're pretty good
no I think if we fought redon
in his prime we wouldn't stand a chance
it wouldn't even be closed either
oh godric could have been like radon
with a horsey if he grafted a horse to
himself
would have been fun to watch
I mean he grafted a [ __ ] dragon head
to himself so
I see what you're saying though
interesting
Christian
thank you for the super sticker that's
very cute
thank you for the 10 bucks man thank you
very much
appreciate it
I'm gonna use these summons because they
are a part of the fight I think that's
fair
W's in the chat for Christian let's go
baby
forgot the lock on
foreign
that's not good
okay I didn't think that was going at me
this is gonna be really hard chat
dodged
oh yeah
oh
foreign
rough chat
yet it patches peace
I didn't notice yet
nice
foreign
no
we're at the clutch up
whoa
we're at the clutch up
I still forgot to put my physic together
by the way
oh [ __ ]
I very rarely see that attack
that's cool when it happens man
God this fight kicks ass
no
hmm
I usually kill radon so fast now that I
don't really see like how [ __ ] cool
he is but oh my God he is so cool
I could go do my visit we'll be okay we
can do it clearly
I don't think anything can take the
meteor attack chat
I think somebody already tested it
I think you instant eye no matter how
much health and negation you have
wow
that's not good
ah
I'm good at dodging that let's go I hit
Alexander instead
no I dodge [ __ ] you what oh
it's gonna be hard guys
this is gonna be hard we really can't
[ __ ] up
I think that's fine Audrey
summon patches right so he can just
[ __ ] leave right away
foreign
it no longer works
I don't have a mimic chat
and I'm not going to use one
foreign
huh
let's see how much this does
not worth I should just do the other
attack there
he was facing that way
I guess he swung it over to me
I'm playing on controller
I just got checked
radon checked
foreign
I was eating
PS5 controller
I mean these games are not designed to
be played on keyboard but you can
whatever works for you you know
and
make it when you might want a different
Ash of War as well
get him boys
that sucks
[Music]
foreign
can't see
[Music]
foreign
can I put body slash on a hammer
well blood's dead
summon summon summon
okay he didn't spawn yet
I stream a lot and it's I wouldn't say
every day
but I scream a lot
[ __ ] missed
go
go boys
oh
get him Alexander
this fight is so [ __ ] awesome holy
[ __ ]
whenever you can't just like murder him
super quick
I'm gonna heal
come on
you guys know if we take too long he'll
jump in the air again
foreign
no Alexander
he's just summon
you guys ever heard the music this far
in
it's epic you hearing this
no don't throw don't throw don't throw
there we go
you have man I don't think I've heard
the whole thing before damn that's
[ __ ] awesome
radon is so much better when you go into
him under leveled at this point
because we'll always go in like pretty
oh look at those legs oh man we'll
always go in super over leveled and then
just beat him to get runes but dude that
fight is one of the best moments in
gaming for me that entire experience
first time through
oh my God what an incredibly good boss
fight
I am a full-time streamer Irby
how's Joy doing out there Chad
she's asleep
what would you consider over leveled I
don't know
I honestly don't know
I'd say what I was at right there was
perfect
level 43 maybe not that one
but
all right guys uh let's level up here I
wonder what we're gonna level
six Stephen let's go boys
excellent excellent
all right all right
can we beat God if we can beat Redan no
godskin Noble's harder than we're done
um
trying to think
because if we can get to Reichard we can
just Farm
Vigor bar will be creeping into the chat
good
they need to give radon more help
are you sure
yep no more leveling once we get to 99
bigger
that's where the challenge will become
very very difficult
you can always go here go across
um
okay I have a plan in my head we're just
gonna try
I got a plan in my head
do you want some mid-max your damage
how about
when it comes to it and I ask for help
you guys can input it there
thoughts on that
there we go
understandable
yeah list Dragon four to six
should be higher higher Health as well I
agree
I don't know I mean do you guys remember
release anyone fight redondant release
wow
he was insanely hard
whoa
insanely difficult
and it was awesome I loved every minute
of it
however
a lot of people bitched and moaned about
it so they changed it
I think not those Church
so that church over there we'll come
back over there
the good old days
can you guys believe Elden Rings almost
been out for a year
can you [ __ ] believe that
Elder during times two speed let's focus
on this Challenge and then we'll come up
with new ones
what did we say for 500 members again
what were we gonna do
what did we say for that one
I remember
it was not made outfit
it was not Ronnie cosplay Ronnie
cosplays a thousand
randomized double boss that's what it
was
that's what it was
I'll think about randomizing it
Speedo run so you guys want me to dress
like this
maybe we don't get demonetized and
banned
or it's 60 Vigor Glory
doesn't it double everything at one
point
what in particular
I want to see how you fight two
millennials
uh I fight her by crying
is that a good answer
I'm really happy that that Rune roulette
video is doing better now than it
initially did that makes me very happy
somber 6 right there
almost at 300 likes holy crap chat like
the stream like it now
now
my clock died
right now
the tears break your PC which means
technically stops Melania
right I just flood the PC with my tears
I think randomize makes chat give you
less suggestions
I don't know dude like
do you guys watch other Elder ring
streamers by chance
I don't so this is why I ask
do other streamers just like
do chats thing
hold on Joy's barking
hey
I think we're safe
good luck
man
she was barking her head off hey
hey
[Music]
she sees another dog outside and she's
not happy about it
hey
hey
look at her dude
can you see her right here
the growling her head off right now bro
no she gets along with other dogs unless
she's at home
so what she's doing and this is the
German Shepherd side of her as she's
protecting our home our area right
when she's out there with the dog she's
the sweetest thing ever
she she doesn't bark at him she just
sniffs him and they play and whatever so
she she never hurts any other dog but
when she's in her area in somebody
else's home she will let you know about
it she will she's protecting that's
that's a part of her breed
so it's not a bad thing she's just
trying to protect
but we know that because she's so sweet
to other dogs when she is with other
dogs
ah hey come here
come here
come on
come here it's okay
she's gonna pout now
so yeah she's just being protective it's
the uh
you know we don't want her to do it
though obviously because we don't want
to make other dogs mad or other people
like oh that dog's scary because it is
scary when she barks but
her intentions are really good so I have
no problem with her barking you know
what I mean
no dad I must protect that's exactly
planning to get more dogs uh you know
whenever I have the means to do so
whenever I have a house I'd probably get
another dog but an apartment
this is a big apartment so she's good
here but
uh to get another dog I'd definitely
wait
she's a German Shepherd Golden Retriever
mix
oh we got 300 likes let's go chat let's
go thank you
I appreciate that
now we're at 299.
someone unliked
well make sure to like the stream if you
get a chance guys make sure to like the
Stream
goofballs all right
[Music]
create a Jake's house one
uh welcome now you guys are doing fine
with that well you please I am saving
for a house in Norway that's like I have
a fund uh for that in my
I won't go too crazy with that but
I'm gonna buy this armor by the way
I've got plans Chad I've got plans
all right
nice
yup Norway
why Norway I've always wanted to live in
Norway
well not always I
I've done a lot of research about Norway
and I've watched a lot of
movies and and TV shows about what it's
like living in Norway and I dislike
their lifestyle more
than uh America
uh my main reason is I like how schools
are in there
for kids
um I like how the work
kind of how the workforce mentality
there is different from here
type of thing
I think people there are in just in
general happier than in America
I don't mind rain
liquor I don't know what city I still
need to visit before I ever like say
okay I'm definitively moving there you
know what I mean
it'd be hard to you distance between you
and your parents I've talked to my
parents about it and they said they
would probably because by the time that
happens they would probably both be
retired
and they said that they would think
about it as well
but that's that's a very long time from
now
go to Alaska I don't want to live in
Alaska
yeah it's really hard Trey
it's really really hard to actually like
move to Norway and become a citizen so I
have to start with that process really
early
but it can be done
it has like the worst food in Europe I
have heard of that
that Norway's food isn't very the best
400 likes you fight falling star beasts
I wonder if we get the 400 concurrent
viewers
then I will
I don't know why I don't get more
viewers I don't I literally don't know
how to get more viewers on YouTube
because on Twitch it's simple if you're
at the top of the the list
um you guys know what I mean about
twitch like top of the list like top of
the of you go to a you go to browse you
go to a game section and if you're at
the top then you get more viewers so
this is how that works YouTube's like
completely [ __ ] different I I
literally don't know how viewership
works
like sub count doesn't seem to matter at
all uh
I I think likes helps but sometimes we
have way more likes than we do
concurrent viewers
um it just seems kind of like random but
then I'll see somebody with like 20 000
subscribers but they'll have like a
thousand viewers on a stream every
stream and I'm like what
kind of interesting
kind of confusing good for them but I'm
just wondering how that happens you know
elderly's kind of dead it's definitely
not as big as it once was but it's not
anywhere close to dead the drawing room
not anywhere close so it's not like you
know if I stream to Minecraft right now
I would get more viewers that's not how
that works
YouTube doesn't have subcategories like
twitch they should
hopefully they integrate that at some
point
um but yeah they definitely should
all
I don't know why I'm in here doing this
can you give me stuff yet from the
volcano I hope you won
well I thought you perhaps play but no
before you can
there before you can no I can't yet I
have to come back don't I
let's go in here
YouTube lives needs a separate platform
I think it needs a separate platform but
they need to do what they've been doing
so they they're very very very very very
slow
very slow with coming out with things
that they should add to YouTube right
but they're working on it so like if you
guys noticed recently my channel and and
everybody's Channel now has separate
categories for their content right
so before I had to unlist every stream
now live streams has its own complete
tab on my channel incredible same for
shorts and same for normal uploads they
used to all mesh together and it was
really ugly now they're all separate
they need to do that on the normal base
platform so like you go to YouTube and
you have videos shorts live and you just
like whatever you want to do you click
that thing they already did that for
shorts
they kind of have it for live but in a
stupid way
you know
it's like on the side to the left in the
middle of all the sections it's it's not
the same it's like shorts
if they do that
then
I think live streaming on YouTube can
literally overtake twitch
yeah we're gonna do all remembrances
yeah YouTube so YouTube's been pushing
shorts a lot as well I've I've started
making shorts bodies started making
shorts a lot of streamers have start
started making shorts helps with your
sub count and it helps with um
just more viewership in general and
they're going to make it that you get
paid
um for shorts which was not uh the case
before
I have a torch and I didn't use it
because I knew it gave you anxiety
okay keep going
favorite remembrance boss it'll always
be radon rodon's my favorite boss in the
game
ad Revenue split for shorts yep I don't
know how much it's gonna be
why is live is a Channel with 60 million
Subs
oh right I don't know
I don't know that one
yeah just figure upgrading only Vigor
Justin
so it limits our weapons a lot
we're trying to get the serpent Hunter
now
I don't even know what that live section
is strips I have no idea what that's
about
what up Ethan
oops
what's the deal with the giant Cliff
skulls and Caleb uh I think that's just
how the rot grows
I don't think those are actual skulls I
think the rot like created them
uh click content made for kids and don't
swear in that video but it's kind of
hard because all the ring is a violent
game
I mean for my main videos I don't swear
usually
on these live streams I do
because I don't really care
I think Joy likes it here she was just
barking her head off at another dog
outside but that's okay
who's getting used to it she's doing
good though thanks for asking
I always get lost right here
you gotta go
over here
I have a hard time not swearing I mean
so do I
favorite part of the lore
I think Queen America's intentions are
the most
interesting thing in the game
along with I think mikola Queen America
and radagon are the three most
interesting people that we need to know
more about to understand more of the
game
foreign
I don't know how well we're gonna do
against the the noble here chat this
this could be tough
this could be really tough actually
but at least we'll have the shortcut to
get here quick
made a beeline for the Beast repellent
torch in North Caleb makes things so
much easier you guys are all about
Vision you want to see
still haven't put anything in my physic
because I'm an idiot but hopefully if we
die here I will uh eat that on
he's like an eye roll and I don't
dad that's rough as hell man that was a
jumping attack too
[Music]
oof
this is a fat l
l
[Music]
foreign
we out here though
God damn chat
foreign
yeah I'm gonna see what the repost does
next
foreign
[Music]
foreign
and I still did it
the pillar wouldn't let me lock on
that's annoying
why is the damage so bad
okay let's see
did that do no damage it literally
didn't do any on the first hit oh my God
are you kidding me
there was no damage zero
got caught
fan
he's resistant to strike
interesting
well he's not resistant to McDonald's
apparently
was that mean
okay you hit me man stop rolling
or
double roll into me
that attack is actually dumb in my
opinion the the belly flop
foreign
I want to understand my chat's obsession
with pots I want to know what it's all
about we're gonna have to do a pot only
run someday
I'm just gonna have to do it
same spot that I got caught in
unfortunately
[ __ ] this guy man
[Music]
so stupid
[Music]
wish I had my physics
huh
cool I even rolled too
that's awesome
all that man
I actually did extremely well
we actually did really good there for a
long time
and then he kind of went a little crazy
hmm
level up vigor
yeah that felt like 20 minutes let's at
least put on a physic I would have felt
more confident with the physic on there
even though we literally only have that
yeah I don't think the noble is a girl
but it doesn't matter
lightning grease
we have a lot of runes we could use I
don't have any grease it doesn't look
like let's let's sell these runes
level up Vigor slightly
I don't know
I thought they were all girls no they're
you're thinking of uh the black knife
assassins
those are all women
or the Newman Race is all women you are
the black knife assassins
I don't even think this will level Us by
the way
why not
it's not gonna level us I should stop
using these
damn
well
we have a physic
you thought radagon was Newman Queen
America's Newman which could mean that
radagon is also Newman since they are
the same person but
that's a different story Queen America's
Newman
like that's in the lore
facts
okay well I don't have a slashing weapon
to use against the noble
great start
foreign
foreign
good at fighting this guy at this point
I'm surprised
I talked I said Words which means I get
instacarman
not a time to use that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
getting hit by Furniture chat
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
just dumb stuff hitting me man so
annoying
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
to believe that's not input reading
to do that attack at that time so
[ __ ] perfectly
[Music]
what is that bro that makes no sense
that attack
it's just like you can't get near him
now that's what that means
I thought he's gonna throw something
[Music]
look I even rolled what what is that bro
I don't understand it
this boss literally makes no sense in
this room I'm sorry it's so stupid
I should probably just die yeah
foreign
at least the music's good that attack is
literally just dumb
it doesn't do that much damage but I
it's like undodgeable
foreign
let me grab my coffee real quick we're
gonna have to do something here I don't
know what
need more vigor right
there's lots of videos out there on the
godskins man
lots of videos
Raptors black feather set I mean we can
get that at some point
sleep pots
hmm
trying to think I don't think our Ash of
war is good at all like I think it's
kind of trash
I wonder if I go back in here can I talk
to Bernal now or do I have to do one of
the I think I do
I have to do one of the quests to even
get his [ __ ]
Gucci Katana guys I have 10 stats for
you gotta remember this
it's only Vigor I can't use some of the
things that you're saying
which is why our our weapons are very
scarce here
yep we need to get the bar off the
screen with the bigger stat before you
can
before you consider
craft a weight loss pot and put it on
the Apostle that's hilarious
um well while I think about it let me go
to the church out here
and uh
get some [ __ ] get a get a get a tear
torches have the highest damage somehow
what
uh what did you say a what now
[Music]
you can use the weapon without the stat
just not the ash of War
hmm
I'm lost it's like over here or
something
bloody conspiracy
bloody right here
this isn't the person that comes out of
here most of the time is it
isn't that the other chick
only spawns if you progress Hero's
questline that's not true
I have done we've had Euro come out of
there to do get moog's tear right or is
his bubble or whatever
or burn the air tree got it that's where
it is okay
gotcha either needs to happen
got it
got it gotta got it
so if you burn the urge tree it'll be
that as well
understood
trying to think of what to do here Chad
maybe I can level my
my Bonker up a bit
I don't really know what I have
many swings we can do with this much
stamina
or smithing Stone fives
I could get the other sacreds here as
well
I have one six
dude leveling
it's the thing we only have to beat this
God skin and then we're good
let me get the other one where where'd
you guys say the other one was again
trying to think
is there another church over here
is it right here
I don't know what Lion's Claw is
what is that
we're trying to get the other sacred
tears so we got this one
there's another one
Windmill Village no dope Ash of War how
do I get it
it's an ash of War found in caled
can I put it on my hammer and it's
actually good
AOE for big weapons
foreign
try bringing the club Affinity back to
10. I was back to standard yeah I was
thinking of that too
good point
a flip slam attack
can't use radagon Source seal it
upgrades uh other things besides bigger
skim
I'm curious how
that'll make a difference I'm gonna go
fight him again
no no let's get the other Secrets here
just gonna go here real quick where is
that
I don't remember where the other
is it is there a church right here chat
Lions Claw is in Fort Gale and Kalin
already have the Crimson Medallion just
not plus two or whatever
south of Hero's grave in Altus
don't remember it so this is Hero's
grave
I just went here I'm pretty sure
I may not have
[Music]
um
what does someone say
so America is bad I should not move
there depends on what your
how you want to live your life
I I personally
do I want to get into this maybe why not
I'm streaming
so
I
find that the American
lifestyle
makes people unhappy it makes a lot of
people unhappy it makes me unhappy as an
example
so
and what I mean by that
is it's the rise and grind
do you have to do these certain
you have to do these certain jobs to be
respected by people in a weird way
so like you need to be a lawyer or a
doctor and if you're not working all the
time and if you're not making tons and
tons of money there are plenty of people
out in the world who think you're a
loser because of that
I'm at a lifestyle where I am trying to
make as much money as I can
while working the least amount
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with that but a lot of people have
problems with it
um
I don't want to work all the time
and I also don't want to do a job just
because it makes a lot of money and I
don't like it
you kind of like in America you kind of
work yourself to death
um
I don't know how to get up here chat
so what I've tried to do my entire life
is to do things that are fun
uh I I work to have
fun and that's it
um
and if in you know obviously I would do
things that I need to do to make money
so that I can live
right but um how do I get up there Chad
is that even where I need to go
the Manila Grace so I have to come from
this way
I do okay
um
other countries don't do that
um so so like when I talk about kids
I want to have kids I've always wanted
to be a dad I've always wanted to have
kids but
I don't want them to grow up
like that I also don't want them to go
to school
for eight hours a day inside what I
would consider a [ __ ] prison
um my high school at least the second
version and and Trey can let me know
what he thinks about this
I thought when they they made Howell our
high school
the new building tray it was awful it
was terrible there were barely like
there was one window in every room and I
just felt like I was in a [ __ ] prison
the entire day I hated that man there we
were there eight hours a day or more
like we had to be there at 6 30 done at
three had homework to do all night like
I just hated it bro
and the countries that I'm looking at
don't want to do that they don't have
their kids go to school
that much they they focus on kids
playing and being kids and being happy
like it seems like other countries
besides America are focused on not
making money
but
being happy
and and I would rather have that
lifestyle
so
yeah you deserve to be homeless if you
don't work 14 to 16 hours a day right
that's kind of the vibe America gives
off I'm not gonna lie whether that's
true or not it's still definitely a vibe
that I I
that you feel while you're here
hopefully that makes sense
how do you know they don't do that in
other countries from people who've lived
there I have
um
friends of my aunt and uncle who have
been traveling around the world like my
aunt and uncle have literally been
traveling around the world they lived in
Norway for a month and they said that
all of these things aren't a thing in
Norway like they just
kids go to school I don't know if like
if this is exactly right but they go to
school for like four hours a day for
four four days a week
and they they focus on community
collaboration instead of uh
testing
right like what do we do here in America
to to determine if somebody is smart or
not you take standardized tests you just
that me like if you're good on those
tests that means you're smart I've never
understood that
ever I choosing out of four answers for
the correct one on such based [ __ ]
questions
whatever I don't want to get too crazy
into that but
yeah
more like six hours of school well it's
definitely less than than here
if that makes sense
but yeah there's lots of reasons
lots of reasons
if we went to school in beautiful
buildings school would be better yeah
like kind of like how the high school
was before
you know like the buildings were
separated Trey
um we had you had to walk outside for
short bouts to get from one building to
another I thought that was great it gave
off a different vibe and then they made
this giant building where you were just
inside the entire day five days a week
uh just terrible bro
terrible
two more laurenia churches
yeah where are those
um I think we're I think we're gonna
work with this and see how we can do
against the noble because we have almost
killed him
so let's go give it a shot
let's give it a shot
even here in Mexico City they do the
same standardized tests just because
North neighbor did it yeah yeah
hopefully I'm making sense here like
obviously not everybody feels the same
way about the stuff that I do and I
think that's totally fine
um
but I want to live my life the way I
want to live my life you know and in
America I just don't think
uh
I I don't know I'd rather be surrounded
by people who feel more so like myself
obviously surround yourself with people
surround yourself with people who
complement your life instead of
complicated
you know what I mean
let's give it let's give this a shot
again
[Music]
foreign
not by a lot but
somewhat
[Music]
yeah I I so like I say Norway because
that's the one I'm the most interested
in
but the um
I'm going I want to visit Europe all of
Europe see everything before I make any
definitive decision on that
foreign
just my aunt knuckle have already been
there so they've given me
some insight
and
foreign
[Music]
do you like it though
that's the difference I think your main
goal in life is to love what you do
so if you're working 14 hours a day and
you love it I don't see anything wrong
with that and you could have that
lifestyle in America you can
for sure
that's why what I'm saying depends on
the person you know
definitely depends on the situation
[ __ ] guy man I'm inside him
can't think of any anywhere else I would
rather not be
like the money and you understand cars
I feel you
and a lot of people like
just making money
so if that's what you're into that's
what you're into for me it's not
he already went stage two right Chad
yeah he did
I got hit by the rolly boy we're doing
pretty good
shouldn't have talked but
it's very clearly doable yeah
[Music]
I dodged it that time randomly okay
foreign
okay now I'm just actively dodging that
attack now interesting
whatever
[ __ ] you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
not doing attacks I like here we go
foreign
nice
we got him
dang bro the game just opened up
the game just opened up to us right
there oh my God
oh my God
just a nice 20-minute fight right there
guys
20 minutes close to it
oh [ __ ] here we go
y'all know what we're gonna do y'all
know what we're gonna do
stick Supremacy right
yo how many likes are we at on the
stream by the way
how many likes
328.
the goal was 200 by the way that's nuts
thank you guys
but if you haven't liked the stream yet
go ahead and go go ahead and do it go
ahead and do it baby
go ahead give it a like
give it a like
all right let's level up our vigor
obviously
yep spin the wheel with the only Vigor
on it yeah let's just waste time
spinning
spinning [ __ ] it's a great idea
level 64.
very nice
we got an hour and a half would I miss I
just beat godskin Noble with the stick
let's go
yeah they're Redemption spins it it
would that would be so like Petty to do
that
hey we completed that challenge man I'm
just a happy guy
yep
ruin roulette was
so difficult
but uh we got through it didn't we
so are we gonna do like no damage with
the serpent Hunter because we don't have
any strength
and we won't have it upgraded for icard
yeah we're definitely using morgot's
great room whenever we get to it for
sure for sure
hello hi fiction how are you
doesn't scale
I thought it scaled with strength
it does it not
rumor lab is one of the best challenges
I've seen
I I did see someone else did it before
me but we had our own experience you
know that's the cool part about that
challenge is like let's say we did it
again it could be a totally different
experience
completely different which I think is
awesome
congrats in the apartment thanks dude I
love it here I I love this place
look at Joy laying on the floor hi baby
Big Stretch what are you doing
she needs some pets man
she's all good oh guys I'm getting that
phone call I'm getting the phone call
everyone calm down
together
check
foreign
all right chat that was a big phone call
that was big you see that floss it made
me floss
I pulled out a floss bro
[Music]
all right
we're back I'm sorry that took so long
that was a big phone call
guess what's coming tomorrow boys
guess what's coming tomorrow oh hell
yeah dude I am so excited for this
I am so excited bro
the couch
the big ass couch is coming and they're
gonna put it right there and you're
gonna lay on it all day
in Europe
okay I'm really sorry that took that
long chat my bad
that's my bad guys my bad
but we're back
okay hold on
yeah that was the phone call about the
couch that's that's a big deal that's a
big deal
from 2 30. sorry hold on I gotta I got a
text I'm sorry
this was big boys
okay
Joy got her ball
yeah Joy's basically saying like all
right cool new BET
okay I'm sorry guys I did warn y'all at
the beginning that I was like okay I'm
expecting a phone call it might come and
it might take a while
[Music]
let's go
oh now now I'm just happy bro now I'm
just happy
that'll that'll
make it much more homey in here
okay let's get it
I'm gonna hit the snake with the stick
foreign
that wasn't worth it
oh I'm fat rolling
just realized I was fat rolling
foreign
difference
holy [ __ ] I'm inside another thing I
don't want to be inside of
foreign
's calling me
shoot
hey Mom
[Music]
okay we're good guys
I know I muted because I was talking to
my mom we're good
couch coming tomorrow guys
couch coming tomorrow oh very well also
Ethan did I miss your five dollar super
chat if I did I'm sorry I I don't think
I said thanks for that man thank you and
he said bigger check
thank you man I think I think I was on
the phone during that
the lands between needs me right now it
does it does she was literally in chat
earlier
so cool bro
does Reichard have total does anyone
know
damn I want that armor
foreign
good
five fifty nine thousand one hundred and
twenty four
you guys know the exact number huh nice
wait why is he doing it again
you all know what to do
I'm surprised you went right back at it
back to life baby right
oh and then God devouring serpent has
30k as well true
oh boy
that was plenty far away I can never
tell the distance on that thing it's not
that far
easy
I have got Reichard down bro
I have got him down
one two three we need a four from EG
okay
we need to grab this did I get a seven
one two three five six
eight we need the seven as well we can
go back to volcano Manor for that
uh
I think we should be okay at a level
vigor
and then be able to upgrade as well cool
yeah we got we got we're good I'm gonna
go
here
wrap around do I have a thing that can
open it
sorry I'm I'm thinking currently
thinking we have two of these so we're
good on that
all right
all right oh seventh Never Dies
EG gives up to four not three
one through four
he's like seven arms you ever look at
the Blasphemous blade there's this like
arms coming off it freaking sick the
character design in this game is like
literally the most top tiered thing I've
ever seen I think
like in any medium not not just gaming
like movies TV shows everything
somber 7 do be kind of a rare boy but it
is over here
and we won't have to spend any runes to
get it and all I gotta do is run
there's pretty poggers
foreign
where's that at Don
I'm I'm blanking on where that is
why did that slide me off
never mind
interesting
my doggy's still over here
he's on the chair now
I don't know how she's going to feel
about movers
but she'll get used to him I'll just put
her in the bedroom
sorry now I'm only all I'm thinking
about is this couch tomorrow chat I'm so
excited
so they said they can go pick it up
between 2 30 and 6 30 and then they'll
bring it straight here
Big Bad Brad really enjoy your content
especially as it relates to the lore of
the game two questions for you is
autonaged a hero of this story and which
ending would you say represents the best
outcome for the lands between thanks
Brad thank you for the five I really
appreciate that
um
let's see I'm glad you like the content
thank you for watching it
so you said are the tarnish the hero of
the story
not at all I don't think so honestly I
think we're going through the game and
literally [ __ ] everything up that's
what we're doing
um
and it's just because we're blindly
following what we're supposed to be
doing what everyone tells us to do
Etc right
um
so no I we're just kind of doing what we
feel is best and that that's what we're
doing
so there's that
and then the best outcome like ending
with the best outcome I would say is
Ronnie's ending personally
because I
theorize that
we're literally leaving the lands
between entirely with her ending
so for me Ronnie's ending I think is the
best we're kind of going to like another
dimension or Another World when we enter
um
like the the moon at the end
I think is a portal
so I think that's the best personally
um I could be wrong on that as well it
could it could be awful I don't know
what is on the other side of that but
that that's what I think
um
but yeah thank you again for the five
that goes right to Joy's treat fund
which we've actually done really good
with today Chad thank you
the treat fun will be up every day baby
Joy you're getting all the treats
you see your head
up
what are you doing
come here
come here
what a cutie man she gets belly rubs
like literally constantly
she's a good girl what time is it
well she's getting kind of hungry chat
but she's gonna have to wait we got [ __ ]
to do
um I need to go get EG right
have we even been to EG yet
no oh man
didn't you guys say there was a portal
right to EG somewhere over here
let me go check that out somebody said
that in chat I'm gonna hold them to it
hey Reef how are you
yep guys this is my turtle
I have a turtle
for a pet
and then we're upgrading the living [ __ ]
out of this thing
I think all the way up to nine right
I think we'll have every somber up to
nine
the moon replaces the Earth tree in the
edge of the Stars that's what that's
what I think
um
we don't know for sure but here we are
almost 400 likes how are we getting so
many likes there just must be new like
there must be a couple hundred people
there's always like a couple hundred or
a little under a little over right
and then it must just filter out people
just like constantly
this game is insane
I just realized I had the HUD Auto on
all right I want it auto it was just on
we weren't getting full immersion
Ronnie DLC
um I mean Ronnie was probably the most
popular
character in the game wouldn't you say
so I bet they would
hey have a great night femi
put the music up sure
we'll go with that
well I presume
oh yeah
all right you guys ready for this we got
our four
one two three four five six
have runes [ __ ]
seven eight nine boom look at us go
now what can we wear
can I wear this
I can and can I wear these
all right guys who are we gonna go mess
up
we gonna go mess up bro
ain't got nothing on me
need more vigor
71 Vigor by the way
more got let's go mess up Golden Godfrey
real quick and the draconic tree
Sentinel
we're gonna go Bop his ass we already
beat Ronaldo Ronaldo's trash we're now
is a stupid idiot actually I really like
Ronald
Barry quests to get Mogan Plus 10.
y'all think we're out here question
right now
bro we're trying to beat the damn game
we're trying to get all the remembrances
bro
we can't waste time
we gotta go go go
dude I'm so pumped about this couch it's
gonna make the apartment just so much
oh dude it's gonna be a game changer
there's nothing I like less in a living
room than like
two chairs you gotta have a couch man
couch isn't necessary
foreign
Godfrey
I think that's it
those are the big boys
I already have a TV I have a 55-inch TV
on the other side damn look at that guy
in that [ __ ]
uh it's just out of you
foreign
not super happy with this damage guys
that's good
I play on PC
what a trickster
yeah this is kind of what we're gonna
get you know like this is just as good
as it gets for us
except of course leveling up one more
time
I thought I could roll
that was my fault
I knew he was trying to trick me there
you see that [ __ ]
man good thing I have a lot of vigor huh
[Music]
foreign
wow
and it kept my jump
this game's dumb stupid idiot
I'm literally getting Elden ringed right
now
literally getting Elden ring right now
thank you
[Music]
no
I'm pretty sure that could have insta
killed me even with this much help
how have I only staggered him once
now you can't use the air thing GLaDOS
but this
if you can get it off and it's kind of
hard to do in this game
does an absurd amount of damage and
physical damage
that was a bigger check right there Chet
because honestly we didn't even play
that well and vigor comes out on top yet
again
I want to get morgot's Rune before we
end stream how long I've been streaming
for it five hours
73 bigger it doesn't feel like five
hours I'm not gonna lie today's been a
lot more fun than yesterday
[Music]
it's like I do this as a job bro
no you're good Mira I appreciate the
reminders on that I actually do because
I do just forget over and over again
I should go get those I want to be
golden Godfrey and then hopefully I'll
remember to go do that
sakiro is nice
Sakura is one of the best games ever
made and if you guys haven't played
sakuro yet you are missing out on just
the best uh combat experience of any
game ever
I think sakiro's combat is better than
Elden ring and any other Souls game it's
literally [ __ ] perfect
I wish they had more sakuro things in
this game
but
it is what it is
yeah a lot of people keep telling me to
play Hollow Knight I might do that
shelter farewell do you think that could
be a stream game
like is hollow Knight like a streamable
game
or would I get like two likes
yeah the deflect system in sakuro is
just like the best bro it's just the
best
okay I've never played Hollow Knight
before
so I don't really know what it is
it's Souls like
I have heard that before
you should David
KIRO is just
I I will say as well sakiro is easily
the hardest
um of all these games wouldn't you say
I would say so
sakiro is incredibly difficult
but satisfying as hell
that's a tough one to get off
[Music]
oh yeah you have that
how am I alive
I'm not
all achievements in Hollow Knight is
borderline impossible
hmm
what do you Bart what hi Joy's hungry
chat but I wanna be
something here
did I just get Vigor checked
at 71 vigor
right
73 vigor
I should just go grab that [ __ ] Grace
down there it's kind of annoying that I
have to run all the way back but it's
honestly not that far
bigger check by a tree how does that
make you feel I feel amazing man
I got a couch coming in tomorrow I'm I'm
ecstatic I got a free couch coming in
tomorrow I should add that as well
it's a big ass couch and it's free
so that's why I'm happy because I was
going to Ikea to buy one
like now I don't have to feels good dude
also someone asked earlier it's black
leather
three sectional couch
think about that
did I just run past it yeah I did
check for bed bugs I mean it's my
parents are giving me the couch so I I
think we're good
I don't think we need a couch email
I want the Newman Rune or Lords
Lords
foreign
the big hits are better
thank you
no way
it's going good Justin how are you dude
there we go
the couch is a mimic
but guys it's a black leather couch
three eight foot sectionals
so it's like this like here's the middle
and then in both sides jet out like this
a touch
but it's eight feet eight feet in the
middle eight feet that way big ass couch
but we did measure we measured in here
before we decided to do this
and it fits
it fits we we did all the measurements
and everything so I'm I'm good with it I
want it get it in here
it's also free yet again so we'll take
it
okay leveling only Vigor is kind of a
meme at this point
my couch is like my whole living room
bro
that's what I'm saying that's what I
want
you know you guys know where I'm sitting
right now the dining room
I put my setup in here instead of a
dining room
sounds like what my generation would do
to be honest
what game do you have more fun with
I think Elder ring I had more fun with
but Dark Souls 3 will always have a
place in my heart Danny
um because it was my first Souls game
if it fits I sits see
there you go
exactly
exactly
I've not completed Dark Souls 1 or Dark
Souls 2 so my experience with dark souls
franchise is limited to Dark Souls 3.
that's fine
play them whenever you want if you want
you don't even have to
enjoy your games chat
enjoy your games
see how are we getting so many likes
I want more viewers
I guess that's always the goal of every
streamer huh
my goal is to be like Tim the tat man
bro like 40K viewers a stream holy [ __ ]
that'd be incredible
and then I could just ignore the people
telling me to use Frost pots
I could just ignore them
I do have a rune Arc we can also buy
them
you lose viewer interaction
yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know why I did that
I was feeling myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
damn
foreign
attack there without getting hit
[Music]
[Music]
that combo is new
foreign
is affecting my sleep any lore
explanation how a spirit is affected by
sleep it's affected by sleep
I doubt there could ever be an
explanation for that my guy
all right
all right we should probably go get
another talisman
sacred tears Jake thank you Miro thank
you Miro listen here's what we're gonna
do Amira are you gonna be here tomorrow
because we're gonna continue this
tomorrow chat Joy is hungry
and she wants to eat look at her she's
got all excited do you want to eat are
you hungry
we're going to continue this run
tomorrow
same time same place
okay
now I won't be able to stream for that
long tomorrow because a couch is
potentially coming well actually it's
coming later at night so I can I can
stream for a while why is this blurry
y'all didn't tell me my camera was all
blurry bro
y'all didn't say [ __ ] whatever I'll fix
it guys thank you for being here I'm
gonna feed the dog and give her a nice
long walk you so excited
so thank you for
um thank you for today today was
fantastic I love this stream today was
so much fun we'll continue tomorrow
hopefully it continues to be fun thanks
for all the super chats all the
donations the Joy's uh fun here
um I just thought it was fun to have
just in case and he was like yeah I'll
give joy treats put it right there
um so thank you for that as well
um
thank you for all the likes we got a ton
of likes this might be the my most liked
stream I've ever had
um so thank you for that
um kind of sucks that I had to do like a
20 minute phone call
uh at some point there but
it is what it is so
thanks for everything chat I will see
you all tomorrow after the stream goes
up make sure to give it a like if you
haven't already
give it a watch if you missed anything
or any part that you missed and remember
to tell me to get sacred tears tomorrow
we're probably gonna struggle so have a
great rest of your day guys and I will
see you then thanks again for everything